le groupe lvmh a cependant pris contact
avec moi pour m'informer du
les propos du rapporteur une offre
unilatérale avait bien été transmise
offre écrite unilatérale avait bien été
transmise au groupe lagardère mais était
restée sans suite bernard arnault nous a
adressé dans l'après-midi une lettre
reconnaissant cette erreur en accord
avec le rapporteur je vous propose de
lui donner acte de cette correction
d'une déclaration réalisé sous serment
le compte rendu de l'audition d'hier ne
sera pas modifié mais nous renverrons
alors à la correction effectuée dans la
journée par bernard arnault
et je tiens à préciser que compte tenu
du déroulement de la rapidité notamment
de la correction en fait qu'une
correction écrite
aucune poursuite judiciaire ne sera
engagée sur ce fondement par la
commission denquête est-ce que vous avez
des points de vue a exprimé sur cette
question vous in rapporteur dont ceux
sur la forme ce qui est dit dans la
commission denquête ne peut pas être
changé ensuite par contre aux propos
tenus il faut joindre la lettre
next un seau et ce sera des vrais bien
entendu aux rapports et au compte rendu
mais on ne change pas on corrige pas ses
propos tenus sont tenus et derrière on
joint cette lettre c'est ce que je
propose comme méthode ou procédure
c'était le sens de ma proposition
également parce que ça vous convient
bien mais je vous propose qu'on fasse
entrer nos invités pour la table ronde
de cet après midi quelqu'un peut aller
les chercher merci effet
des salles pour que vous ne soyez pas
trop proches les uns des autres sur la
table et respecter au mieux les
distances sanitaires
[Musique]
bien mes chers collègues je vous propose
donc que nous reprenions nos travaux
avec le rapporteur david assouline nous
avons souhaité consacrer une table ronde
aux nouveaux médias créés dans des
circonstances certes diverses mais qui
témoignent tous à leur manière du
dynamisme de la presse dans notre pays
en invitant quatre acteurs importants de
ce secteur monsieur edwy plenel vous
avez été directeur de la rédaction du
quotidien le monde entre 1996 et 2004
puis vous avez fondé le site web
d'information mediapart en 2008 qui se
cinghalais singularise en particulier
par son engagement et des investigations
au long cours quelques-unes ayant
particulièrement marqué l'actualité
politique mediapart a inauguré le
concept d'un site d'informations payant
alors que la gratuité était à l'époque
le modèle dominant vous revendiquez
aujourd'hui près de 220 mille abonnés et
votre pari économique semble gagnée
puisque votre parution dégage des
bénéfices je précise que à partir de
l'été 2010 9 il ya un peu plus de onze
ans après la création mediapart a changé
sa structure de gouvernance afin que la
totalité des parts du média soit détenue
par un fonds à but non lucratif vous
pourrez peut-être nous en dire un mot
lors de votre intervention liminaire
monsieur eric fottorino vous avez dirigé
la rédaction du monde de 2007 à 2011
soit un peu après monsieur edwy plenel
votre départ a été particulièrement
commenté vous l'avez évoqué dans votre
ouvrage paru en 2012 mon tour du monde
depuis cette date vous n'êtes pas rester
inactifs vous avez fondé notamment
l'hebdomadaire à succès le le 1 ainsi
que des trimestriels comme america qui
s'est achevée en août 2020 ou zadig ces
deux dernières publications ont inauguré
en france les mots qu soit un objet
éditorial à mi chemin entre le livre et
la publication de presse monsieur
nicolas beytout vous avez dirigé les
rédactions s'ils ont des échos entre
1996 et 2004 et du figaro entre 2004 et
2007 vous avez également été président
du groupe de médias de lvmh de 2007 à
2011 en 2013 vous avez créé le quotidien
l'opinion je vous cite en 2013 pour le
décrire la ligne éditoriale de mon
journal sera libérale pro business et
pro-européenne
le capital d'autres gens là n'est pas
officiellement connue vous pourrez
peut-être nous en nous en parler en 2019
vous avez racheté l'agefi en plus de
votre regard sur la concentration des
médias vous pourrez nous éclairer sur le
modèle économique qui est le vôtre
madame isabelle roberts vous êtes
présidente du site web d'information les
jours
ce site a été créé par des anciens du
journal libération en 2016 et repose sur
un modèle d'abonnement votre
particularité éditorial consiste à
traiter les sujets sous forme de
feuilleton que vous donner mes
d'ailleurs obsession vous consacrez
depuis cinq ans une obsession à vincent
bolloré que nous avons auditionné cette
semaine
je crois que cette obsession compte plus
de 170 épisodes à ce jour en plus des
conditions de développement propre à
votre média vous pourrez peut-être nous
apporter quelques informations sur ce
sujet nous vous remercions bien entendu
d'avoir pu tous les 4 ou vous rendre
disponible nous interrogeons en
particulier sur deux aspects d'une part
les opérations de concentration sont
souvent présenté comme indispensable à
l'avenir de la presse par l'assise
économique qu'elle offre face aux enjeux
concurrentiels et aux yeux de
transformation numérique
or vous apportez d'une certaine manière
la démonstration que des modèles
alternatifs et indépendants peuvent voir
le jour évidemment vous nous précisera
dans quelles conditions d'autre part
nous sommes attentifs aux garanties
d'indépendance des rédactions sont elles
aujourd'hui suffisante peut-on les
renforcer sans mettre en péril
l'équilibré économique comme vous voyez
de sujet important sur lequel nous
allons débattre cet après midi je vous
propose l'organisation suivante qui
commune du reste à toutes nos auditions
je vais vous laisser la parole
pour un propos liminaire de huit minutes
chacun je serais assez stricts sur le
temps tout simplement pour permettre
d'abord que chacun d'entre vous
s'exprime et puis surtout que nous
puissions avoir avec vous un échange à
travers des questions réponses je vous
précise mais vous le savez que cette
audition est diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du sénat et elle fera
également l'objet d'un compte-rendu bien
sûr qui sera publié enfin je rappelle
pour la forme qu un faux témoignage
devant notre commission denquête
seraient passibles des peines prévues
aux articles 4 134 tirs et 13 14 et 15
du code pénal je vous précise également
qu'il vous appartient le cas échéant
d'indiquer vos éventuels liens
d'intérêts ou conflits d'intérêts en
relation avec l'objet de la commission
denquête je vais vous invité
successivement madame et messieurs a
prêté serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité en levant la main
droite et en disant je le jure je
commence par vous monsieur plenel
sur fottorino madame roberts cb tous je
vous remercie et je vous donne la parole
pour 8 minutes je ne sais pas qui
commence
je donne le top départ en commençant par
vous alors monsieur plenel
[Musique]
monsieur le président je suis leur
apporte leur mesdames et messieurs le
sénateur merci de votre invitation une
précision tout de suite je ne représente
pas un site web mais un journal en ligne
statut que la création de mediapart a
permis officiellement d'obtenir c'est à
dire la neutralité des supports nous
sommes des journaux quels que soient les
supports et reconnu par la commission
paritaire des publications et agences de
presse je viens donc m'exprimer devant
vous au nom d'un journal novateur
totalement numérique
qui a défendu une totale indépendance
au coeur de la modernité de la
révolution digitale en d'autres termes
qui a voulu défendre le meilleur de la
tradition un journal sans publicité sans
subventions qu'elles soient publiques ou
privées et comme vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le président depuis 2010 900
actionnaires avec un modèle totalement
innovant inédit en france d'une
structure à but non lucrative le font
pour une presse libre qui est désormais
la structure qui sanctuary sur le
capital de mediapart le rends
inviolables
incessibles non spéculent à bhl
d'ailleurs je crois que vous avez prévu
d'auditionner le président du fpl
prochainement nous sommes aussi membre
fondateur
d'un syndicat ou qu'elle les jours sont
également adhérent qui est le syndicat
de la presse indépendante d'information
en ligne
ce syndicat qui tout récemment est
devenu le premier syndicat des éditeurs
de presse en nombre d'adhérents ils
représentent désormais 262 éditeurs pour
320 publication
je vais maintenant répondre à ce qui est
l'objet de votre commission denquête
qui est cet impact de la concentration
accélérée
des médias sur la démocratie et en
préambule je voudrais vous rappeler une
tradition parlementaire de notre
histoire démocratique
l'objet de votre commission
n'est pas une question simplement
économique ou une question accessoires
nous sommes devant une question centrale
qui préexiste aux droits de vote qui
préexiste à l'existence d'institutions
démocratiques qui préexiste même à
l'affirmation d'une république le 13
août 1789
jean sylvain bailly maire de paris
désigné au lendemain de la prise de la
bastille faisaient une proclamation
affiché sur tous les murs de la capitale
qui disait la publicité est la
sauvegarde du peuple jean sylvain bailly
n'était pas n'importe qui il fut le
premier président du tiers état le
premier président de l'assemblée
nationale cette proclamation et ce n'est
pas indifférent été faite à propos d'une
question importante qui était le prix du
pain et la spéculation sur la farine et
sur l'alimentation de première nécessité
en d'autres termes le secret des
affaires directes ont aujourd'hui la
publicité et la sauvegarde du peuple
cette formule se trouvait sur toutes les
médailles des colporteurs de journaux à
la fin de l'année 1789
le droit de savoir le libre accès à une
information indépendante loyal honnête
et pluraliste et la condition de la
vitalité d'une démocratie c'est en
proclamant ce droit que par la suite les
révolutionnaires de 1789 ont pu créer
des institutions démocratiques
l'objet de votre commission
derrière l'accélération de cette
concentration c'est le renforcement
d'une très longue histoire ce que le
fondateur du quotidien le monde hubert
beuve-méry appelait la presse
d'industrie dans une conférence célèbre
de 1956 intitulé la presse et l'argent
nous sommes des entreprises et la
première garantie de l'indépendance
c'est la rentabilité
et nous montrons à mediapart que l'on
peut être rentable en ne faisant que du
journalisme là où d'autres détruisent de
la valeur et ruinent la confiance dans
l'information que disait beuve méry ans
1 66 c'est que la presse d'industrie
c'est autre chose qu'une industrie de
presse c'est le mélange des intérêts il
suffit disait-il et c'est là qu'est le
mal que cette information là il pas
porter quelques préjudice à des intérêts
matériels et très précis ou à l'occasion
qu'elle les serv efficacement hubert
beuve méry le disais au souvenir de
l'effondrement de la presse et des
médias des années 30 où
la perte d'indépendance la vénalité de
la presse a accompagné la montée des
haines et des virulence dans le débat
public
la question qui est devant vous derrière
cette concentration horizontale en
nombre de médias
sans précédent c'est sa rencontre avec
une concentration verticale totalement
propre à la france qui n'existe pas
ailleurs dans aucune grande démocratie
les conflits d'intérêts sont désormais
généralisé avec des groupes de médias
qui accumule d'autres métiers d'autres
activités la publicité le groupe havas
bolloré lvmh premier annonceur de france
propriétaire des échos et du parisien
l'armement
le figaro et propriété d'un groupe
d'armement et ne traitera pas évidemment
les questions qui mettent en cause ce
groupe notamment dans des scandales de
corruption en inde par exemple autour de
la vente de rafale la téléphonie ce soit
et c'est faire ce soit free les tuyaux
contrôler les conclu on pourrait citer
toutes sortes d'autres
domaines la question de
l'incompatibilité entre une activité
économique industriel et éditoriales
d'information et l'existence d'autres
intérêts est au coeur des décisions que
nous attendons devant vous et elle va de
pair avec la nécessité de renforcer ce
que n'a pas su faire la loi bloche c'est
à dire l'indépendance des rédactions en
leur donnant un véritable statut
juridique qui leur permet de se protéger
par un droit d'approbation est un droit
de révocation de des directeurs
éditoriaux
les deux précédentes auditions de votre
commission ont été le spectacle d'une
fable ce ne sont pas des philanthropes
ce ne sont pas des industriels
d'ailleurs ils n'investissent pas dans
les médias ils achètent de l'influencé
de la protection ils ne sont pas libero
politiquement la meilleure preuve en est
et la phrase de bailly vous le rappeler
l'opacité opacité du capital
le pacte d'actionnaire qui lie le monde
libre c'est à dire monsieur niel mathieu
pigasse et anciennement monsieur bergé
est toujours confidentiel pour la
société des rédacteurs du monde les
comptes annuels de ses journaux de ces
médias ne sont pas publiques et vous
l'avez rappelé sur l'un d'entre nous
les subventions qu'ils reçoivent
n'étaient pas publics jusque avec le
spill nous menions la bataille pour
qu'elles soient publiques qu'on sache où
va cet argent public et enfin les
accords noués avec les plateformes
légales femmes sont toujours
confidentielle et le secret des affaires
a été opposé à une mission d'information
de l'assemblée nationale qui s'en est
ému en reprenant nos propres
protestation et ma propre audition sur
le sujet l'obligation de transparence
devrait être au coeur de vos conclusions
j'en conclus il me reste en effet 20
secondes j'en conclus pour dire que
derrière ce spectacle que je viens de
décrire
il y a une responsabilité de la
puissance publique je voudrais terminer
par cette question des aides publiques
j'ai dit que médiapart comme le style
d'ailleurs a pris position contre ces
aides directes
aujourd'hui elle représente un quart du
chiffre d'affaires du secteur et savez
vous quoi parmi les neuf groupes de
presse qui touche
61% des aides directes
se taille la part du lion les
milliardaires les oligarques qui ont mis
la main sur ces médias lvmh le figaro le
monde libération achètent sont les
premiers ils ne mettent pas la main à la
poche ils tendent la sébile d'une part à
l'état c'est à dire à notre argent et
d'autre part aux gars femmes merci merci
nous reviendrons bien sûr sur un point
vous avez abordé mais ces photos rideau
[Musique]
il faut appuyer sur le micro voilà
c'est le président monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
je voudrais moi aussi
faire quelques rappels historiques
j'avais noté la même citation cadeaux y
de beuve méry
et ajouté qu'il disait vous ne verrez
derrière moi ni banque ni église ni
partie
je voudrais revenir à une histoire -
ancienne que la révolution mais la
période qui a été une grande période
d'espérance en france qui a été celle de
la libération 1944 les ordonnances de la
presse et en préparant cette cette
audition je me suis plongé dans beaucoup
de textes qui m'ont fait me confortez
mais il en avait besoin
dont la nécessité de ce métier et de ce
métier libre et indépendant et j'ai
finalement trouvé cet article de l'
ordonnance du 26 août 1944 qui à mes
yeux résume le malheur français de la
presse pourquoi
il ya un passage de ceux de cet article
sur lesquelles beaucoup se sont arrêtés
qu'on a souvent commenté qui dit la même
personne ne peut être directeur on
parlait pas de femmes de peut-être
directeur de plus d'un quotidien
1944 c'est l'esprit du cnr l'esprit de
la résistance information n'est pas un
bien comme les autres donc elle doit
être affranchi des forces du capital des
forces de l'argent il ya eu en effet la
presse vénale de l'entre-deux-guerres et
d'ailleurs il est neuf mais bernard mary
correspondant à prague l'avait bien vu
lorsqu'il travaillait pour le temps
cet article en fait y creuse déjà une
partie de notre malheur d'aujourd'hui
bien sûr il a été contournée je vais pas
vous raconter le groupe hersant comme
avait été au le groupe prouvost avant
lui mais une personne ne peut diriger
qu'un quotidien ça voulait dire qu'on a
acté au nom des bons sentiments qui
pavent l'enfer des bonnes intentions on
a acté une forme de sous-capitalisation
chronique c'est ce que dit le sociologue
jean-marie charon de la presse tout
simplement parce qu'effectivement on
pouvait pas avoir constitué un groupe de
presse mais ce qui est plus intéressant
à mon sens c'est le début de cet article
9 de l' ordonnance du 26 août 44 qui
d'ailleurs a été abrogée par une loi la
loi léotard de 1986 je lis dans le cas
d'un hebdomadaire dont le nombre
d'exemplaires tirés excède 50 mille
exemplaires ou d'un quotidien dont le
tirage excède 10 mille exemplaires nul
ne peut exercer les fonctions de
directeur ou directeur délégué
accessoirement à une autre fonction
soient commerciales soient industriels
qui constituent la source principale de
ses revenus et de ses bénéfices
autrement dit si il y à des patrons de
presse ils doivent être issus de la
presse ils ne doivent pas considérer que
la presse et comme on disait une
danseuse quelque chose qui vient en plus
pour des raisons dont on a vu ces
derniers jours dans vos auditions
qu'elle était presque comique c'est à
dire tout le monde se dit très petit on
et monsieur arnaud on est monsieur
bolloré on est tout petit par rapport
aux gars femmes etc et on reçoit en
effet edwy plenel l'a dit on reçoit les
aides les aides de l'état qui sont
calculées de telle manière que je ne
vois pas comment on peut faire renaître
d une presse libre et indépendante avec
des entreprises qui prennent des risques
lorsque finalement on donne de l'argent
de poche à des milliardaires
ce premier point de cet article 9 il
faut le j'allais dire le renforcer par
une autre dimension si je résume au
lendemain de la guerre la libération
des journaux sont condamné pour
collaboration et sons cesse de paraître
et il ya une sorte de nouvelle donne qui
qui intervient on pourrait dire façon un
peu caricaturale la presse se partage
entre les gaullistes et les communistes
ligue des gaules espagne les rédactions
les communistes prennent les imprimeries
et là devient un deuxième j'allais dire
péché mortel de notre de notre presse
c'est que en donnant cette prérogative
au ollivro syndicat du livre on a
commencé à mettre en oeuvre un système
j'allais dire une usine à gaz qui a
finalement été le fossoyeur de bien des
journaux puisque les coûts de production
c'était à la fois la production dans les
imprimeries aussi la distribution des
journaux il m'est arrivé de d'évoquer
ces questions dans ces mêmes lieux au
moment de la sphère presstalis est bien
évidemment à grever très lourdement le
coût de la presse la possibilité de se
moderniser d'embauché d'aller chercher
de nouvelles idées avec de nouveaux
moyens
ce qui fait que aujourd'hui et c'est eu
une autre cause de ce qui arrive c'est à
dire cette hyper concentration c'est pas
une concentration une hyper
concentration
ce qui fait qu'à partir des années 70
lorsque les chocs pétroliers chutent de
la croissance le chômage les journaux
sont de plus en plus cher dans le
pouvoir d'achat on commence à voir les
premiers ratés de la diffusion les
premières baisses de diffusion même si
la presse écrite auront encore de beaux
jours
les recettes publicitaires commencent
aussi à diminuer et donc on va voir se
créer les conditions économiques d'une
telle fragilité de la plupart des
quotidiens
qu'évidemment ils deviendront des proies
très facile pour les appétits
d'industriels qui croyais moi ne sont
pas du tout dans une sorte de mécénat
mais sont plutôt dans l'idée de faire
avancer à la fois leurs dossiers
économiques et financiers avoir de l'
influence mais aussi avoir une influence
politique je crois que ces deux si on
n'a pas en tête ces deux levier que ces
industriels veulent actionné en
possédant des journaux on est dans
l'histoire de la presse raconte et asus
est alors pour terminer je pense que il
faut avoir en tête
troisième conséquence je parlais du
poids de l'histoire avec les bonnes
intentions les ordonnances de 44 et puis
le livre deuxièmement le moment de la
crise qui va s'accélérer évidemment avec
la fin des années 90 et l'irruption de
l'étincelle numérique est bien le
troisième point c'est une crise de
confiance généralisée dans notre pays
sur la formation
c'est tout ce pour quoi on fait des
journaux c'est à dire éclairer l'opinion
l'informer lui dire le vrai il faut pas
être le plus rapide il faut être le
meilleur et pour être le meilleur il
faut évidemment en avoir les moyens et
je pense que ce qu'on a constitué l'un
ça vient de longue main
rappelez-vous 1995 les premières grosses
critiques de la presse au moment des dvd
des grandes manifestations autour des
des réformes juppé 2005 le nom
référendum constitutionnel européen sont
des moments qui ont marqué une un
abaissement de la crédibilité de la
presse et puis le mouvement des gilet
jaune pour se donner des points de
repères plus récents qui montre finma a
finalement quoi qu'il ya une sorte de
perception par nos citoyens les citoyens
d'une connivence entre la presse et les
élites élites politiques élites
économiques l'idée de ne plus être
représenté de ne plus être informés
correctement et donc si vous voulez les
rédactions ne sont pas des chiens comme
n en laisse certes mais je voudrais
terminer avec la fable edwy parlé de
fable tout à l'heure du loup et du chien
vous savez le loup qui crèvent de faim
et puis finalement le chien lui dit
viens viens chez moi tu vas bien manger
on est bien traité et donc le loup a
bien envie d'y aller puis chemin faisant
ils l'interrogent mais tu as une marque
là sur le coup qu'est ce que ces deux
noms ça c'est rien du tout et puis
finalement le loup à mesure qu'ils
approchent de de la maison du chien
insisté et le chien fini par dire oui il
faut dire que quelques fois on nous
attachent eh bien oui je pense que cette
presse hyper concentré ces groupes hyper
concentré ce sont des lieux où
régulièrement pas tous les jours on
attache la liberté de la presse
l'indépendance et les rédactions merci
beaucoup
madame roberts
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs merci de me
recevoir
aussant votre invitation je me suis
demandé à quel titre vous souhaitiez
m'entendre celui de journalistes qui au
sein des jours enquête au long cours sur
vincent bolloré notamment depuis sa
prise de pouvoir sur canal + puis sur le
groupe lagardère de journalistes ayant
exercé une quinzaine d'années à
libération j'ai suivi le secteur des
médias ou si vous souhaitiez montendre
en tant que dirigeante et cofondatrice
du site d'informations indépendant les
jours point fr avant de faire face à une
évidence les deux sont intimement liés
les deux sont liés parce qu'ils
rejoignent la même question cruciale
pour la démocratie est au coeur de cette
commission denquête comment dans un
paysage médiatique qui se concentre à
toute vitesse garantir la liberté
d'informer comment garantir que les
citoyens soient bien informés j'ai lu
avec attention aujourd'hui le baromètre
annuel de la confiance dans les médias
publié par la croix neuf personnes
interrogées sur dix considèrent qu'il
est important ou essentiel pour le bon
fonctionnement d'une démocratie d'avoir
des médias et des journalistes
indépendants du pouvoir politique et
économique mais un tiers seulement
estiment que c'est le cas aujourd'hui
si nous avons créé les jours en 2016
c'est sur ce constat on n'a jamais eu
autant d'informations qu'aujourd'hui
mais on n'a jamais eu autant de mal à
être bien informé on retrouve les mêmes
dépêche copier coller d'un site à
l'autre sous cette masse d'informations
protéiforme le lecteur se retrouve
asphyxié noyé sous une info sans mémoire
la réponse que nous avons décidé
d'apporter au jour point fr c'est celle
de faire des choix dans l'actualité
d'agripper des sujets d'enquêté et de ne
plus lâcher d'inventer la forme
innovante du journalisme en série qui
raconte une histoire vraie épisode après
épisode
et de le faire dans un média indépendant
détenu en majorité par ses salariés son
pub et sur abonnement donc financée par
ses lecteurs et qui n'a de compte à
rendre qu'à ses lecteurs dans une
relation de transparence et de confiance
avec cette conviction le numérique n'est
pas le lieu de l'info qui ne coûte rien
qui ne vaut rien et la crise de la
presse n'est pas une fatalité
j'ai pu éprouver la liberté de ce modèle
la joie professionnelle qu'elle procure
mais aussi sa difficulté les sacrifices
qu'il entraîne pour atteindre un
équilibre durement acquis qu'il faut non
seulement maintenir mais dépassés dans
un environnement de plus en plus
concurrentiel
c'est dans ce cadre qu'en tant que
journaliste j'enquête avec raphaël
garrigos depuis six ans sur l'instant
bolloré depuis six ans nous avons pu
raconter révélé ses méthodes comment il
prend le pouvoir sa brutalité son
interventionnisme comment il met les
antennes au service de ses intérêts
comment ils censurent comment ils
arrivent à se débarrasser de la
quasi-totalité de rédaction non pas une
non pas deux mais trois fois comment il
a transformé une chaîne d'information en
haut-parleur pour l'extrême droite en
tremplin pour eric zemmour
avant donc d'étendre cette emprise et
cette idéologie au groupe lagardère
pour se retrouver à moins de trois mois
d'une présidentielle à la tête d'une
machine de guerre idéologique et tout
cela dans une impunité quasi totale
ce travail là ces révélations là nous
avons pu les faire parce que nous sommes
à média indépendant que nous ne
subissons pas de pression de personne
parce que nous avons inventé armé d'un
modèle éditorial innovant qui nous
permet de creuser de ne jamais lâcher un
sujet
alors j'entends beaucoup armés il n'y a
pas de vincent bolloré bien sûr il n'y a
pas que vincent bolloré le problème des
industriels propriétaires de médias et
plus vaste est justement un des soucis
avec vincent bolloré c'est qu'il a
déplacé le curseur du joug cam
industriel peut faire peser sur un média
qu'il a envoyé un message à tous les
propriétaires de médias
regardez ça vous pouvez le faire purger
une rédaction vous pouvez le faire qu'il
a par contre par comparaison rendu tous
les autres acceptable il y avait un
journaliste du groupe lagardère qui
récemment me disait tu te rends compte à
quel point on en est pour que bernard
arnault passe pour un chevalier blanc
alors aujourd'hui on en est là et c'est
une catastrophe pour la liberté
d'informer pour l'information que chaque
citoyen est en droit d'exiger
rigoureuse onat respectueuse de
l'éthique et de la déontologie
aujourd'hui dans le monde des médias
audiovisuels on s'achemine vers un
schéma
qui est qui et avec un secteur privé
bipolariser ultra puissant avec d'un
côté tf1 m6 de l'autre bolloré vivendi
lagardère et au milieu le service public
parce que derrière l'écran de fumée des
gaffes à caen vous ressert à chaque
édition la réalité elle est celle là ce
sont entre eux et au niveau national qui
vont se battre
alors même si elle arrive bien tard la
question est qu'est ce qu'on fait
maintenant
la réforme profonde voire la réécriture
de la loi 2009 86 est une évidence tant
elle est obsolète et qu'on s'attaque
aujourd'hui au numérique avec des outils
de l'âge de pierre
et puis il faut trouver les dispositifs
les verrous qui permettent de se
prémunir des actionnaires industriels
interventionniste voire destructeurs
afin de protéger les rédactions et les
lecteurs
plusieurs pistes ont été déjà évoqué ici
peut-être qu'on en reparlera que ce soit
maintenant matière de gouvernance des
médias ou en termes de dispositifs
juridiques comme le trafic d'influencé
en matière de presse
puis il faut se donner les moyens de
faire respecter la loi aussi peut-être
qu'on peut discuter du csa art comme
enfin a contrario soutenir ceux qui ont
fait le choix risqué est difficile de
l'innovation de l'indépendance afin que
le journalisme soit en mesure comme
l'écrivait albert camus en 1939 dans son
manifeste pour un journalisme 2 pour un
journalisme libre qui fut censurée
d'ailleurs de refuser ce qu'aucune force
au monde ne pourrait lui faire accepter
servir le mensonge il ya urgence
c'est le président c'est le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les membres de la
commission
je vous remercie de votre invitation je
vais vous donner en quelques minutes une
vision par certains côtés différente de
celle que vous avez entendu sur la
concentration de la presse et surtout
essayer de vous proposer une ou deux
pistes pour
essayer d'en de sortir de ce débat j'ai
créé l'opinion comme vous l'avez dit
monsieur le président il ya neuf ans
après avoir passé de 35 ans de ma vie
comme journalistes
essentiellement aux échos puis au figaro
et avant de revenir aux échos comme non
plus journaliste mais comme patron de
presse
et c'est fort de cette expérience
multiple plus des chronique quotidienne
sur rtl europe 1 et france inter que je
me suis lancé à partir de 2013
la création de l'opinion depuis ce
moment le site et le journal ont grandi
nous avons embauché nous avons pu faire
l'acquisition il ya deux ans d'un média
spécialisé dans la finance et l'économie
qui l'agefi aujourd'hui le petit groupe
c'est un petit groupe surtout à
l'échelle de des personnes que vous avez
auditionné les jours précédents fait un
chiffre d'affaires d'environ 25 millions
d'euros emploie 140 personnes dont 85
journalistes je voudrais attirer
l'attention de la commission sur
plusieurs points d'abord un constat
la france a dans à peu près tous les
domaines de l'économie des champions
mondiaux des entreprises leaders c'est
vrai dans l'industrie l'automobile
l'aéronautique l'espace coluche le
bâtiment les travaux publics l'énergie
la chimie les systèmes informatiques
c'est vrai dans les services la banque
l'assurance
les mobilités les aéroports la gestion
de l'eau des déchets l'ingénierie
partout sauf dans les médias la france
n'a pas de champion de taille mondiale
ni de champion international dans les
médias on pourrait incriminer évidemment
le problème de la langue français
beaucoup moins parler que l'anglais
est bien sûr que l'espagnol mais la
francophonie exister et de toute manière
travailler à l'international ce n'est
pas forcément travailler en français
donc ce n'est pas la bonne excuse entre
mon point de vue la cause de la
faiblesse du secteur des médias vient
plus sûrement du choix des des choix qui
ont été faits depuis plus de 50 ans pour
la france
interdire la concentration des médias
avec des lois nombreuses à commencer par
la loyère sens
évidemment bien connus qui ont eu pour
objectif comme le disait eric fottorino
d'empêcher la constitution voire de
démanteler des groupes existants motifs
très noble bien sûr préserver la
diversité
protéger les journalistes
les journaux sont donc restés petit sans
grands moyens sous capitalisées ils ont
peu investi avec des coûts de structure
et les coûts d'exploitation extrêmement
lourds entre autres comme l'a dit
également eric fottorino pour des
raisons liées un deal avec les
organisations syndicales la cgt en
particulier certains se sont faussement
rassurées d'être seul sur leur
territoire en position de monopole avec
l'illusion de contrôler leur marché et
personne ou presque n'a pu développer
des stratégies de croissance plusieurs
décennies plus tard c'est à dire
aujourd'hui nous avons nous aboutissons
à linverse exactement de ce qui était
recherché il y a moins de journaux moins
de journalistes dans les journaux qui
ceux qui survivent mais on s'interroge
quand même sur la concentration des
médias
on s'interroge et c'est ma deuxième
remarque qu'on ne voit pas que à côté de
quelques grands groupes à l'échelle du
pays en tout cas une myriade de petits
groupes ou de petits médias parfois de
tout petits médias sont apparus les
nouvelles technologies dont vous avez
amplement parlé dans les précédentes
positions ont fait émerger des médias
des usages nouveaux pas seulement des
journaux print comme on dit dans nos
métiers a seulement des radios des
télévisions mais des sites des applis
des réseaux sociaux on verra j'en suis
sûr il y a ainsi plus de concentration
mais aussi plus de nouveaux médias et ça
fait du mal au fond très classique c'est
ma troisième observation très classique
en économie et qui est très bien décrit
depuis plus d'un siècle a plus une
entreprise grossit plus elle prend du
poids plus elles laissent des espaces
des niches dans lesquels plus petit que
peuvent se glisser les géants sont moins
agile moins à l'affût des nouveautés -
capable de remettre en cause leur
organisation par exemple est ce que ford
general motors cet élan this peugeot ont
empêché un un tonneau mais tesla de
naître de devenir ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui est de bousculer totalement
marché comme il le fait alors vous
trouvez peut-être ça théorique laissez
moi vous donner quelques exemples dans
les médias est ce que c'est un journal
économique
financier ou boursier qui a créé
boursorama non est ce que c'est un
magazine féminin qui a créé
aufeminin.com non est ce que c'est un
journal de santé ou de bien-être qui a
créé doctissimo non à chaque fois ces
journaux étaient trop installés pas
assez mobile trop sûrs d'eux pas assez
rapide sur les nouvelles opportunités
il y à l'échelle de la france quelques
très grands groupes dominants mais vous
avez devant vous malgré tout quelques
exemples de petits médias de moyens
médias qui se sont créées dans des
interstices et qui peuvent assurer à
leur mesure bien sûr une partie de la
diversité des médias en france
4e observation la france serait gelé
entendu à plusieurs reprises dans vos
travaux le pays dans lequel les
milliardaires possède la presse comme
j'ai entendu pur fois je me suis dit que
ça devait être une vérité qui étaient
installés dans vos esprits je voudrais
simplement vous rappeler deux choses
d'abord ce qui se passe à l'étranger et
ce qui se passe depuis des décennies à
l'étranger en angleterre plusieurs
grandes fortunes ont depuis longtemps
investi dans la presse robert maxwell
qui était quelqu'un qui s'était enrichie
dans le négoce puis dans l'édition s'est
ensuite lancé dans la presse pas
forcément de façon très brillante on
sait comment ça finit mais tout de même
il a été un grand patron de presse au
sens de sa dimension plus près de nous
les frères barclay propriétaire de très
nombreux palaces et de chaînes de grande
distribution le ritz à londres par
exemple qui rachète ensuite le groupe de
telegraaf et l'ensemble des publications
associés en italie la famille agnelli
évidemment bien connu propriétaire entre
autres de fiat avec la république a et
la stampa qui devient un immense
éditeurs de presse et qui est
aujourd'hui propriétaire de lee
économiste
en italie toujours la famille de
benedetti qui avait été propriétaire de
la république a et qui fortune faite
dans l'informatique
possède donc la république a pendant un
moment et puis espresso au canada la
famille desmarais
dont la fortune est dans l'exploitation
de lignes de transport public puis de
gestion de portefeuille et de services
financiers qui devient propriétaire du
grand journal la presse le canada encore
avec les fers bronfman edgar bronfman en
particulier fortune faite dans les
alcools et les spiritueux qui devient
des actionnaires influent de vivendi aux
états unis et j'en termine par là le
rachat de washington post h-2b hausse a
beaucoup marqué mais on oublie aussi
carlos slim multi milliardaire mexicain
qui a été celui qui a un moment sauver
le new york times qui était en grande
difficulté voilà pour la soi-disant
spécificité française on a évoqué déjà
cet après-midi le fait qu'en france
aussi cette spécificité entre guillemets
n'était pas récente françois coty
industrielle du parfum entre les deux
guerres jean prouvost héritier d'une
dynastie textile là aussi entre les deux
guerres qui reprendra paris-soir
embauchera pierre lazareff ça n'est pas
indigne dans le panthéon de de la presse
avant d'accueil marie claire et un petit
hebdo de sport qui à l'époque
faisait du sport il appelait match et
qui deviendra ce que ce que l'on sait
aujourd'hui vous l'avez compris je pense
que à côté de la concentration des
médias qui est un phénomène non
seulement
inéluctable un peu partout dans le monde
mais parfois souhaitable à condition
bien sûr d'être dans une économie
régulée à côté de cette concentration il
faut favoriser la naissance et la
croissance la multiplication de médias
qui à leur tour doivent croître et
assurer la diversité ancré dans
l'opinion et en me battant parfois
contre les pouvoirs publics pour
survivre j'ai pu constater que le
système actuel était calibré pour
protéger les insiders pas pour favoriser
l'entrée des outsiders les concurrents
ne nous ont pas rendu la tâche facile
mais ça c'est la règle c'est normal
c'est le jeu en revanche et c'est
beaucoup plus problématique le carcan
des règles qui régissent la relation
entre un média nouveau et la sphère
publique est presque impossible à
desserrer je sais qu'un premier pas a
été fait avec la création d'un fonds
pour l'émergence mais il reste beaucoup
à faire cependant il terminerait par la
favoriser la création et la croissance
d'entreprises de médias à côté des
groupes concentré ne suffira pas il faut
aussi lutter contre le vol de contenu et
la captation de chiffre d'affaires
publicitaire par les grandes plateformes
mondiales vous en avez beaucoup parlé au
cours des différentes auditions et
quantité d'idées sont déjà sur la table
je me permets juste de suggérer une
piste toute simple mais qui changerait
énormément de choses il compris dans le
domaine de la lutte contre la haine en
ligne et l'anonymat il vous suffirait à
vous législateur de conférer à toutes
ces plateformes
la qualité d'éditeur de médias avec la
responsabilité sur la publication de
contenu qui va avec responsabilité
juridique et judiciaire bien entendu ce
serait un véritable bouleversement dans
la pratique et le développement de ces
réseaux qui sont en réalité chacun l'a
compris les médias les plus puissants du
monde je vous remercie merci aux autres
on va commencer les premières séries de
questions en commençant par celle du
rapporteur david assouline
[Musique]
oui c'est vrai que bonjour et merci
d'avoir répondu présent à notre
invitation c'est vrai que cette table on
a un peu évolué par rapport à
ce que j'avais imaginé au départ puisque
je voulais qu'il y ait des médias
indépendants et qu'on traite la question
des médias indépendants
et pour ses seins mediapart et êtes-vous
fottorino ensuite on a vu qu'il y avait
d'autres demandes et d'autres souhaits
et moi j'aurais préféré que à ce moment
là ils puissent avoir des auditions
en direct les uns avec les autres parce
que effectivement les sujets sont tout à
fait différent selon les médias que vous
représentez et dans leur modèle est
aussi dans les approches que vous avez
donc là ça fait un peu table-ronde mais
on peut remédier à cela y compris en si
vous le souhaitez en faisant en sorte
qu'il puisse y avoir si on n'a pas été
au bout de ce que vous souhaitez avoir
des auditions directe de ceux d'entre
vous qui le souhaitent alors ma première
question c'est
[Musique]
sur le cadre
bien entendu la cette commission n'est
pas tombée du ciel elle a été voulue par
un groupe politique du sénat qu'il a
décidé de la mettre en tête de gondole
des sujets puisqu'on a droit qu'à une
niche par an donc
en tête de gondole dans un
nos moments d'actualité urgente avec
toutes les questions sociales sanitaires
extractives
prégnant dans le pays nous avons décidé
ça a surpris certains de mettre cette
question au coeur et
de fer qu'elle soit acceptée par le
sénat parce qu'il faut qu'elle soit
acceptée quand même pourquoi parce que
ça a été soulignée par certains d'entre
vous et notamment edwy plenel
dans la résolution qui la met en place
nous considérons que un phénomène qui
est existant depuis longtemps et il a
pris des formes diverses à certains
moments a eu d accélération importante
dans les années 2010 et aujourd'hui avec
des grosses opérations au cours ou qui
viennent de s'achever
on se réveille avec un paysage
de l'audiovisuel des médias de la presse
et donc des conditions mêmes de la
liberté de la presse
complètement modifié et un petit peu
comme si la société le subit cas n'y a
jamais eu de débat pour
disons et appréhender l'ampleur du
phénomène et voir comment légiférer en
86 il ya eu un débat il ya une loi et
tout le monde est d'accord ça a été
relevé par edwy plenel aussi que ne
pouvait pas être envisagée alors les
vertes les concentrations vis verticales
et verticale au sens où effectivement
maintenant les problèmes les
fournisseurs d'accès peuvent produire
des contenus peuvent diffuser à voir les
tuyaux et donc sur l'ensemble de la
chaîne de valeur avoir le même
propriétaire donc
on a constaté aussi dans le domaine de
la presse qui est plus traditionnel que
un des fleurons de cette diversité de
cette liberté c'était la pqr notamment
telle qu'elle est issu de la deuxième
guerre mondiale avec une énormément de
titres qui reflétait toutes les opinions
issu de la résistance
et c'était presque comme ça que s'est
forgée dans la conscience des
générations qui ont suivi cet exercice
de la liberté d'opinion et qu'on se
retrouve avec des grands groupes
avec moins de journalistes parce que les
grands groupes c'est pas plus de
journalistes c'est moins de journalistes
qui contrôle plusieurs titres voire des
régions entières et ça pour l'exercice
de la démocratie une modification du
paysage et puis à la presse numérique et
c'est là que j'aurais ma première
question
à vous parce que c'est ce qui est
aussi quelque chose que vous avez en
commun pour l'essentiel de ceux qui sont
dans cette table ronde effectivement
l'émergence d'une presse numérique
et qui est bien une presse et même ça a
dû être combat vous l'avez souligné y
compris pour cueillir les mêmes droits
en termes de tva je me souviens avoir
mené ces combats
seul au début ensuite rejoint pour que
ça soit le même niveau de tva
comment j'ai envie de vous poser la
question comment
vous réussissez dans cet environnement
où on nous dit qu'on n'est jamais assez
gros quand on a des empires déjà
médiatique à tenir notamment qu'avec des
abonnés sans publicité ça c'est la
première question et d'adressé et être
vie plenel et à l'ensemble de ceux qui
sont ici comment on peut encore être
présents dans les kiosques avoir une pré
presse papier alors qu'on nous dit que
c'est plus possible de de développer les
atouts de la façon dont vous avez fait
et et la vision mais aussi ce que ça
veut dire tous les jours
est bon alors après j'ai des questions
plus particulièrement suite que je
poserai ensuite pour parce que pour
l'opinion
ça permet aussi d'éclairer les opinions
diverses dans cette table s'est pas
complètement le même type de
capitalisation d'actionnaires de
fonctionnement de notre restons sur la
question de la diffusion est importante
à vendre alors abordé les questions sur
le modèle et si vous pouvez compléter
avec si vous avez un point de vue
sur ce que pourrait signifier
un approfondissement des lois existantes
pour permettre l'indépendance des
rédactions même quand il ya des
concentrations c'est à dire le statut
renforcé le statut juridique des
rédactions c'est quoi concrètement pour
vous parce que moi j'ai bien sûr j'ai
cette réflexion et c'est vers cela que
je veux qu'on aille mais la formule
exacte entre ce qui est presse écrite
médias audiovisuels et c est forcément
différent de première cette question
donc sur la diffusion
internet ou papier et et puis la
question du statut des rédactions qui
commence
allez-y me supplie
messieurs président monsieur le
rapporteur madame et messieurs les
sénateurs le côté divers ou ou
hétérogène de cette table ronde
dans les modèles et d'une certaine
manière dans les démarches
et finalement une bonne occasion pour
avoir aussi un débat qui vous est clair
vous avez entendu un plaidoyer qui
reprend celui que vous avez entendu hier
et notamment avant-hier
il nous faut une concentration pour
avoir des champions nationaux
nous nous défendons un idéal
démocratique qui est un idéal
professionnels
et ce n'est pas un drapeau une identité
nationale qui recouvre cette question
d'idéal démocratique et d'idéal
professionnels je rappelle encore une
fois ça a été cité ont évoqué coty en
clair la presse vénale qui a accompagné
la montée de l'extrême droite et le
basculement de la france dans la
collaboration avec vichy donc j'insiste
beaucoup
des concentrations des grands groupes
nous sommes au coeur d'une question
essentielle qui est la question du
pluralisme de la diversité donc il faut
d'abord avoir des champions démocratique
une presse aussi respecté que le
guardian et que le new york times il
faut avoir des champions professionnels
qui ne donne pas le spectacle que vous
avez sous les yeux mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs d'un débat public qui est
totalement corrompu par le déversement
des opinions et non plus d informations
nous notre métier c'est produire des
informations l'opinion appartient à tout
le monde des vérités de fête d'éclairer
le débat public et que les vérités
compris celles qui dérangent soit au
coeur du débat public
ce n'est pas le déluge des opinions pour
tuer des informations je dis ça parce
que votre question et idées et qui lui
serait parce que nous avons voulu
démontrer que le laboratoire mediapart
mediapart et nous publions chaque année
tous nos comptes au centime près chaque
année un exemple de transparence que je
crois unique dans le détail même de
cette transparence
dans notre secteur
nous avons aujourd'hui comme vous l'avez
dit plus de 200 mille abonnés payants et
avec une audience qui va à quatre
millions et demi 5 millions selon les
périodes nous faisons cette année 2021
les chiffres seront rendus publics en
mars 22 millions de chiffre d'affaires
et un résultat net après impôts et
intéressement de 4 millions soit 18% du
chiffre d'affaires sans subvention sans
argent public sans actionnaires privés
sans aucune man en faisant simplement du
journalisme du journalisme du
journalisme c'est la voie du sursaut il
n'y en a pas d'autre la question c'est
pour que ce sursaut ait lieu il faut que
l'écosystème soit sain je redis devant
vous que ceux qui vous font le plaidoyer
laissez-nous faire des champions
français détruisent la valeur et la
confiance
demandez
les chiffres d'un journal économique la
tribune et comment il a été détruit par
bernard arnault et lvmh
monsieur bernard arnault est peut-être
industrielle de luxe comme les
compliments de certains de vos collègues
l'ont dit hier mais dans la presse il ne
sait pas faire il sait détruire de la
valeur y compris économique moi je suis
un patron de presse ici devant vous je
crée de la valeur mediapart ces 120
emplois sans compter évidemment tous
ceux qui collaborent à ce journal nous
avons commencé à 25 au départ nous
créons de la valeur nous comptons une
entreprise rentable profitable quand je
dis qu'il détruise de la valeur comment
justifiez-vous élus de la nation que la
troisième fortune mondiale ou la
deuxième je ne sais plus premières
fortunes européennes
groupe de cette ampleur soit le premier
bénéficiaire d'argent public dans la
presse
la question portait oui mais je sais ça
risquerait excusez-moi
la diffusion me serais déçu pour
monsieur le président je comprends bien
mais nous sommes venus ici nous sommes
là pour parler de votre sujet central
nous nous sommes un petit poisson ou
vertueux dans une mer et l'eau les
poissons qui nous intéresse et mais le
petit pression non expliquez-nous votre
modèle non parce que justement le petit
poisson aux courageux le modèle je viens
de vous l'expliquer lisez mediapart et
il est sûr que vous n'aurez pas entendu
sur six news les révélations de
mediapart mercredi matin le jour où vous
avez entendu monsieur bolloré sur la
corruption de deux chefs d'état
africains et les documents qui montrent
l'implication directe de monsieur
bolloré c'était un cadeau pour votre
commission pour vous lui posiez la
question bien vous voyez nous parlons de
ça c'est le sujet de votre commission
c'est l'exemple je sais toujours si vous
le permettez le sujet de notre
commission c'est nous qui le définit son
nom mais dont vous apéro géant intitulé
excusez moi réel jeu bien monsieur
lesage usine de l'impact de cette
concernant c'est juste de répondre aux 2
questions du rapporteur je réponds à ma
famille parce que c'est vrai que c'est
une spécificité vous avez posé dès le
début sur les diamants je réponds à
mi-classement puisqu'il s'agit de ma
question je vais vous dire exactement
pas ma question
je considère que dans cette audition
nous demandons à chaque personne
auditionnée de nous donner un point de
vue sur la l'objet de notre commission
denquête c'est à dire la concentration
dans les médias et il y à des médias ici
qui ont un point de vue et même se sont
constitués là dessus comme les jours et
suivent principalement à faire donc je
trouve tout à fait normal que cet aspect
de ma question on puisse y répondre
comme le souhaite monsieur edwy plenel
et puis il y a les questions sur leur
propre modèle économique je vous voulez
décrit le modèle économique et vous le
connaissez je vous ai donné ses chiffres
et je pourrais vous en voyez tous les
pdf de nos bilans annuels je redis ce
chiffre c'est le moment où vous m'avez
interrompu monsieur le président le
groupe lvmh en 2019 et c'était avant les
aides du poids pris en coûte de 2020
2021 se taillaient la part du lion avec
plus de 16 millions d'euros d' aides
publiques comment expliquez vous qu'un
industriel richissime ne met pas la main
à la poche pour son activité économique
je ne vais pas citer les autres chiffres
vous les connaissez nous sommes au coeur
d'une question centrale cela a des
conséquences
cela a des conséquences sur la qualité
de l'information
le désaccord que je voulais souligner
avec nicolas beytout car c'est l'utilité
devant vous c'est d'entendre ces
désaccords
la sdj des échos
quand monsieur bolloré est venu monsieur
par noé venus prendre leur journal en
2007 la société des journalistes
alertés par l'exemple de la tribune une
rédaction qui n'est pas suspecte d'être
anti business anti réussite économique
est
suspecte devoir de la défiance à l'égard
du monde les affaires a publié la
déclaration suivante la presse est un
métier monsieur arnaud dans laquelle on
pouvait lire ceci un journal plus encore
quand il s'agit d'un journal économique
qui perd du crédit perd des lecteurs
fait n'est par perdre de l'argent nous
ne voulons pas connaître ce sort écoutez
cette phrase dans aucun grand pays
capitalistes au monde d'ailleurs c'est
un journaliste des échos président de la
société des journalistes dans aucun
grand pays capitalistes au monde
d'ailleurs le principal quotidien
économique n'est possédé par la première
fortune locale par un groupe gérant des
dizaines de marques est l'un des plus
importants annonceurs de la place
c'est la question
vous pouvez penser qu'elle est hors
sujet mais c'est la question centrale le
modèle encore une fois de mediapart a
servi d'exemple à tout le monde nous
avons été pionniers sur l'abonnement
tout le monde s'y est convertie nous
avons été pionniers sur la
reconnaissance du statut de la presse en
ligne ça a été utile à tout le monde
nous avons été pionniers sur l'égalité
de traitement et nous la fait payer
c'est à dire l'égalité de traitement
entre presse-papier presse numérique et
cela a profité à tout le monde vous
savez on quelle manière nous sommes des
réformateurs volontaire de l'écosystème
de notre secteur aujourd'hui cet
écosystème est objectivement pollué par
un conflit d'intérêt général
l'intervention d'actionnaires qui ne
sont pas des industriels de
l'information qui cherchent de l'
influence et de la protection et qui ont
d'autres intérêts à défendre et qui font
en sorte que les informations qui
dérange leurs intérêts ne paraissent
plus dans les journaux ou les médias ça
fait qu'ils contrôlent merci de
transmettre un peu
la parole aussi aux autres c'est une
table ronde donc aux autres intervenants
messieurs fottorino
alors je n'ai pas parlé du 1 jusqu'à
présent mais je vais vous dire quelques
années me donner quelques éléments de ce
cette publication qui est né en 2007 et
qui a été ensuite suivi de trimestriels
comme vous l'avez rappelé comme america
qui a duré les seize 16 numéros les
quatre ont de la présidence trump et
puis à dick sur sur la france au plus
près et le dernier trimestriels
s'appelle légende et il incarne
l'actualité à travers des grandes
figures contemporaines
pour m'arrêter sur le un sur notre
modèle
je voudrais dire évidemment que
lorsqu'on a commencé à y réfléchir on
était déjà dans une ère numérique très
approfondie très avancé et on nous
disait qu'il n'y avait plus de salut que
par le numérique et je me souviens
d'avoir entendu
edwy dire quelque chose de très vrai sur
le modèle c'est vous supprimez trois
coups d'un coup vous supprimez le coût
du papier le coût de son impression le
coût de sa distribution
et face à cette espèce d'accélération de
vitesse
évidemment la vitesse étant devenu
quasiment la norme de nos sociétés
ils paraissaient hagards 2 de lancer une
publication papier
pour autant je pense que lorsqu'on
oppose papier et numérique on est dans
une vision un peu paresseuse des choses
c'est à dire c'est trop facile de dire
ah oui mais le papier c'est mort puisque
le numérique et là
je pense que tous les médias et
l'histoire l'a prouvé tous les médias se
sont ajoutés et ne se sont pas éliminés
la radio n'a pas éliminé
le papier la télévision n'a pas éliminé
la radio etc ce qui évidemment était
plus problématique avec le numérique
c'était que c'était un média total qui
donne non seulement à lire mais aussi à
voir et à écouter
mon analyse était très simple c'était
que je crois que la presse écrite vie et
vit encore une crise de l'offre
c'est-à-dire qu'elle n'a pas su se
renouveler dans un environnement qui lui
a complètement changé premièrement et
deuxièmement on a abandonné ce qui est
quand même la formation intellectuelle
de notre civilisation depuis au moins le
xvème siècle c'est-à-dire depuis avant
le codex c'est à dire un certain nombre
de mots sur une page et le savoir l'an
le savoir profond l'assimilation la
compréhension du monde elle est passé
d'abord par là et tout d'un coup nos
cerveaux ne sont pas devenus autre chose
ils se sont augmenté on a on a des
cerveaux qui sont plastique qui peuvent
accepter la vitesse à condition d'avoir
aussi par ailleurs la lenteur et la
profondeur à partir de là j'ai fait une
analyse avec avec mon équipe de ce
qu'était ce que cherchait les lecteurs
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent électeurs c'est
très compliqué de savoir ce que veulent
les lecteurs on est quelques-uns dans
cette salle chacun d'entre nous veut pas
la même chose et pourtant on peut se
réunir autour d'un journal qui soit
encore une fois numérique ou en papier
qu'est-ce qui étaient les grands défauts
à mais à mes yeux de la presse telle
qu'elle est
d'une part la presse est trop longue qui
lit un journal qui finit un journal ça
veut pas dire que les articles sont trop
longs ça veut dire qu elle ne choisit
pas qu'elle a fait des hypermarchés de
l'offre alors qu' il ya un mot qu'on a
perdus dans ce métier c'est le mot
hiérarchie qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
information importante qu'est ce qui
vaut un gros titre qu'est ce qui vaut
s'incline qu'est ce qui ne vaut rien
rappelez-vous camus là encore on mesure
la liberté d'un journal non seulement à
ce qu'il dit mais ce qu'il ne dit pas
donc déjà sélectionné faire le tri est
rare cheese et c'est très important très
important si vous ne dites pas
l'essentiel si on fait des gros titres
pour des choses qui ne servent à rien et
qu'ils n'éclairent pas le lecteur
a fait un journal pour rien
la deuxième chose c'est l entre soi les
journalistes écrivent pour les
journalistes et tout ça se mord la queue
nous écrivons pour des lecteurs et des
lecteurs qu'on doit prendre pour des
gens intelligents on doit s'adresser au
meilleur du lecteur et l'information
doit le mettre en confrontation avec le
meilleur de ce qu'est chaque lecteur pas
le racolage pas les bases instant il ya
sûrement plusieurs manières de le faire
edwy plenel le fait depuis très
longtemps avant mediapart avec de
l'investigation pour notre part on l'a
fait différemment on l'a fait par des
enquêtes de fond et je dois dire que la
première et seule grande enquête qui est
parue dans la presse française sur le
scandaleux presstalis a été publiée dans
le 1 sous la signature d'un journaliste
ancien journaliste de libération
philippe qui faire et on a compris
pourquoi
aucun journal ne parlait de presstalis
parce que tous les grands dirigeants
étaient autour de la table qui gérait
presstalis et qui s'accordait des
ristournes des passe droits etc je ferme
cette parenthèse restait
donc ne pas être dans l'antre soi et
donc nous on a inventé une offre qui est
ce qu'elle est c'est à dire quoi
d'individualiser un sujet chaque semaine
pas deux pas trois 1 et ce sujet là le
faire visiter par tous les savoirs le
savoir sensible de la littérature de la
poésie de l'art et le savoir savons bien
sûr des chercheurs dans tous les
domaines et le tout médiatisé par le
journaliste parce que nous sommes des
journalistes et effectivement ce qui
nous a amené à financer aussi bien des
grands reportages que des longues
enquêtes sur des formats puisque le
format du 1 est très particulier
commence par un a4 une petite feuille il
se continue par un format tabloïd et il
termine par un très grand poster
imaginez qu'on peut publier 35000 signe
alors c'est un peu technique mais 35,6
dans la presse aujourd'hui vous ne
publiez pas des formats comme cela donc
il ya une immense liberté est une
immense exigence est toujours considéré
que le lecteur c'est à lui d'abord est
exclusivement constate presse et pas au
métier pas au confrère même si les flics
on ferait évidemment on les fait
travailler alors bien sûr les abonnés on
a aujourd'hui près de 25 mille abonnés
nous avons lancé une application
avant-hier donc au bout de cette onde
lancer une application qui a tout de
suite trouvé beaucoup de public et ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir qu
effectivement moi je ne pose pas
numérique et papier c'est un peu le
judoka on prend l'énergie de l'ain pour
la porter vers l'autre la plupart de nos
abonnés arrive par notre site nos
abonnés papier arrive par le numérique
donc je pense est absurde et ça a pas
beaucoup de sens d'opposer les uns et
les autres il faut jouer des
complémentarités en revanche
je crois que pour répondre à l'autre
partie de la diffi de la difficulté oui
et de votre question qui est une
difficulté c'est vous savez chaque jour
je me demande ça va durer nous non plus
on n'a pas un gramme de publicité si on
est là c'est parce qu'on a des lecteurs
c'est tout on n'a rien d'autre à la
différence de médiapart on a deux cent
mille euros de subventions tous les ans
le led au pluralisme voilà
par ailleurs pas de publicité nous
sommes les propriétaires de notre de nos
publications et donc c'est nous qui
décidons chaque semaine ce qu'on fait
quand on veut faire qu'un numéro sur les
migrants même si on sait que les
migrants personne ne veut en entendre
parler on le fait et on se moque un peu
de savoir si ce sera une grande vente ou
une vente moyenne où il ya des sujets
auxquels on tient et on les défend les
sujets européens etc donc c'est vraiment
de l'éditorial et les gens qui nous
achètent sont là parce que c'est cette
démarche qu'il pilote qui leur plaît
maintenant sur la difficulté de de
prospérer de durée le dur métier de
durée
je suis toujours consterné même un peu
et bailly de voir que à aucun moment
lorsqu'on veut lancer un média qu'on a
une idée qu'est ce que c'est un bien
c'est une idée d'abord c'est une idée
une conviction et une intuition c'est
les deux
si vous frappez à la porte d'une banque
il appelle la bpi la banque publique
d'investissement ils vont vous recevoir
avec un grand sourire très gentiment si
vous leur dites que vous faites des
médias du média papier il vous raconte
pas tout aussi gentiment les banquiers
comme cela qui vous prêtent toujours
deux parapluies quand il fait beau on en
a pas besoin on a besoin de gens qui
prennent des risques avec nous et donc
si vous voulez à aucun moment une banque
ne m'a prêté un euro
il a fallu attendre cinq ans pour qu'on
ait un petit droit de découvert si
jamais on l'a pas utilisé quand il ya eu
la sphère presstalis ont été au delà du
découvert comme vous l'imaginez ce que
je veux dire c'est que tant que dans
notre pays il n'y aura pas des
institutions financières jury des
banques pour accompagner le risque de
médias avec des prêts à taux zéro avec
des facilités
on trouvera d'autant plus scandaleux
effectivement que ce soit les
milliardaires qui au lieu d'investir eux
mêmes se prennent cet argent à la fois
d'être direct et dead à la distribution
de la presse voilà donc si vous voulez
on dure parce que c'est des contenus et
je crois que tant que l'offre est à la
hauteur des attentes identifier des
lecteurs il ya bien sûr de la place pour
une presse libre indépendante inventive
mais les conditions économiques ne sont
pas toujours réunies pour faciliter ses
créations
ces deux questions
je vais essayer de répondre de manière
un peu courte sur le modèle économique
eric fottorino à raison un média c'est
d'abord une idée c'est c'est une
conviction
et ensuite nous on s'est lancé en 2016
et comment fait tout en 2016 quand on
décide de se lancer dans un média on
regarde ce qui s'est fait avant et en
matière de presse numérique parce que
chez nous aussi c'est un choix et ça ne
s'oppose pas au papier non plus
on regarde ce qui a fonctionné ce qui
n'a pas fonctionné et si on prend les
pionniers de la presse sur le numérique
qui sont mediapart et rue89
l'un avec un modèle gratuit l'autre avec
un modèle payant sur abonnement et on
regarde ce qui marche et ce qui marche
c'est devant nous c'est médiapart
et pourtant dieu c'est moi je m'en
souviens à l'époque quand mediapart
s'est lancé si tout le monde se moquait
d'eux jamais ça marchera mais comment
des gens prêts à payer pour
l'information sur internet c'est c'était
vraiment dans les rédactions c'était
c'était incroyable ce qu'on pouvait
entendre puis aujourd'hui on a devant
nous le plus grand succès sur la sur la
presse numérique donc sur le modèle
économique bien sûr on s'est inspiré de
ce qui a fonctionné et le modèle de
l'abonnement c'est le modèle le plus pur
mais c'est le plus difficile aussi
donc pour justifier un abonnement il
faut avoir un modèle original différent
qu'on va pas trouver chez les
concurrents
nous notre proposition je vous en ai
parlé c'est notre modèle éditorial qui
consiste à raconter l'actualité en série
à faire des choix dans l'actualité pour
lutter justement contre la submersion
par des contenus copiés collés con qu'on
trouve partout
et effectivement c'est difficile ski ski
c'est facile de se lancer finalement ce
qui est ce qui est difficile c'est de
durer au moment on n'est plus le truc
nouveau tout le monde nous connaît et
puis on a intéresse plus grand monde
donc ça ce sont des choix éditoriaux et
ses choix éditoriaux
effectivement comme dit eric nous aussi
par exemple depuis le début des jours
quand je me souviens au début dé joie on
avait on avait un grand tableau on avait
écrit les thèmes sur lesquels on voulait
travailler qui deviendront aussi deux
obsessions et parmi ces thèmes y avait
des migrations moi je peux vous dire
qu'on mesure ce qui est lu chez nous ce
qui est et c'est pas ça fait pas partie
des sujets les plus lus en revanche
c'est des sujets on continue de traiter
puis il ya aussi quelque chose c'est que
nous quand on s'est lancé en 2016 c'est
un moment où on s'apercevait ça s'est
vérifié que les gens étaient de plus en
plus prêts à payer pour des contenus sur
internet
c'est vrai pour la vidéo c'est vrai pour
la musique c'est vrai aussi pour la
presse et ce choix de ne faire que du
numérique il se justifie par en fait
nous nous avons trouvé que la presse sur
le numérique
n'utilisait pas à fond tous tous les
outils que peuvent apporter le numérique
on peut faire de la vidéo on peut faire
de la photo on peut on peut inventer une
manière de lire sur internet qui soit
aussi confortable que sur le papier et
ça on a tenu à le faire et avec ce
dispositif des séries
aujourd'hui la majorité de nos lecteurs
ont moins de 35 ans ils ont moins de 35
ans et souvent on a des témoignages de
lecteurs de moins de 35 ans qui nous
disent en fait je ne lisais pas la
presse avant je suis venu à la presse
par vous parler jour
monsieur b tout
le modèle que nous avons essayée de
construire depuis une petite dizaine
d'années est effectivement assez
différent de ce que vous avez entendu
expliqué à l'instant
moi mon intuition a été un peu comme
celle de mes trois prédécesseurs
d'essayer de faire quelque chose qui ne
s'était pas fait avant je sentiment que
la presse couvre est suffisamment la
presse les médias au sens large c'est
vrai que finalement insuffisamment
l'actualité dans un marché qui était en
attrition avec de moins en moins de
consommateurs et que si je cherchais à
faire la même chose que les autres je
risquais de décliner comme les autres et
donc j'ai décidé de faire quelque chose
qui était à peu près à l'opposé de ce
que j'avais fait pendant 35 ou 40 ans
pendant 35 40 ans j'avais essayé en
dirigeant des journaux de les rendre les
plus complets possibles les plus
exhaustifs entre guillemets possible
n'augmentant le nombre des journalistes
en inventant le nombre des pages de
chacune de ses rédactions les échos les
filles héros en particulier là j'ai fait
l'inversé j'ai dit on va faire un média
qui a huit pages
qui
choisit ses sujets de façon très
sélective qui n'a pas de brefs qui ne
fait qu que des sujets long que des
papiers avec des angles et ceci à une
époque où rappelez vous on est en 2012
la mode est au clic massif les fermes à
cliquer en quelque sorte ou des
entreprises aligne des des gens qui
sortent à peine des écoles de
journalisme qui reprennent des dépêches
et qui cliquant permanent et qui font
clic et le shaq fait du skate et est le
triomphe absolu du journalisme une
époque moi je fais exactement l'un vers
ce et donc je décide de créer un média
qui est un média numérique avec une
extension papier en martelant une espèce
de moto qui s'est révélée
curieusement exact internet c'est
l'audience le papier c'est l' influence
et la réalité a été celle là dès le
début on est entré par exemple dans les
revues de presse avec une part de voix
qui était très largement supérieur à ce
que nous étions à l'époque donc le
modèle a été celui là d'une combinaison
entre
le site internet et un quotidien papier
je dois attirer votre attention sur le
fait que
en touchant du bois je pense que notre
longévité en tout cas le tracé est fait
c'était la première fois et c'est la
première fois
depuis libération c'est à dire en 1974
qu'un quotidien papier de presse
d'information politique et générale
se lance et survit info matin a tenu
deux ans j'informe a tenu deux mois
on a eu de la presse gratuite qui a
d'ailleurs fait beaucoup de mal à la
presse payante beaucoup beaucoup de mal
et même à la notion de lire parce que la
presse gratuite est vraiment un produit
très dégradée par rapport à ce que
peut-être la presse mais nous sommes les
seuls et pourquoi est ce que nous sommes
les seuls parce que les coûts que nous
avons à gérer et la complexité de ce
système de la presse quotidienne car un
peu évoquée
avec fottorino pour une presse qui n'est
pas quotidien mec presse papier avec du
print et de la distribution cette
complexité amène des coûts qui sont
absolument gigantesque nous continuons à
penser que la presse papier a un rôle à
jouer qui est complémentaire et
différents de ce qui est internet et
c'est pour ça que je continue à
développer ce modèle
deuxième édition du rapporteur
vous êtes nombreux à vouloir intervenir
donc si chacun peut poser des questions
relativement synthétique pour que
d'abord vous puissiez répondre et que
chacun puisse poser ses questions
oui donc où beaucoup de choses ont été
dites mais on voit bien que
pour la partie 2 de notre intérêt de cet
après midi qui est vos propres modèles
et je répète
j'attends aussi des expressions sur
notre sujet globalement elles vous
commencez à avoir lieu mais sur les
modèles on voit bien qu'à des modèles
complètement différent leur sueur pour
en revenir à l'opinion parce que c'est
complètement différent votre votre
modèle puisque
vous vos actionnaires principaux outre
vous qui êtes à 24,4 c'est bernard
arnault qui détient 24 8 c'est à dire un
peu plus que vous mais mme bettencourt
qui a 8
4 millions est à 17,1 ken fisher ce qui
est un des actionnaires du quotidien
libéral
état
est investi un million d'euros depuis
2021 et en tout 3 5 millions et robert
rupert murdoch injecter au moins 2
millions d'euros
détenu à 7,6 pour cent dans vos points
donc ça c'est un autre modèle je passe
pas sur tous les autres actionnaires
parce que c'est en général des gens qui
ont les moyens
jean philippe thierry ancien pdg d agf
bien philippe louis dreyfus
l'armateur
et cetera et cetera
donc
la question je vous pose
à cause de votre modèle c'est celle que
d'ailleurs j'ai posé de façon très
offensive à monsieur bolloré et à
monsieur bernard arnault nous ne l'a pas
complètement vue mais moi je sais ce que
j'ai dit est ce que j'ai demandé
c'est comment exercer une liberté
dans quel travail d'expression des
journalistes
d'approfondissement quand le
propriétaire
a des intérêts sur les sujets que vous
pouvez avoir un traité et on sait bien
que l'opinion quand même traite beaucoup
aussi les sujets économiques les sujets
commerciaux etc même il est lui souvent
pour ça
il n'ya pas d'interférence
avec tous les intérêts du groupe lvmh
notamment et notamment certains comptent
ils font le tri et moi je vais pas vous
lire des pages parce qu'on va me dire je
suis trop long
il ya d'autres vous diront alors je suis
pas assez précis mais je vais dire la
chose et vous verrez de à quoi je fais
référence
le nombre d'articles pour parler des
activités de lvmh est beaucoup plus
important dans vos colonnes que ce que
ceux sur ses concurrents j'ai les
chiffres je peux vous les citer ou alors
des sujets éviter qu'ils ne sont pas
traitées par l'opinion quand ils sont
critiques vis-à-vis de
vous répondez quoi
je réponds c'est ce sont pas mes propres
enquêtes je vais les chercher dans la
presse car moi j'ai pas une armée
d'enquêteurs bien sûr parce que nous ne
sommes pas aux états unis avec les
sénateurs qui ont 25 collaborateurs pour
enquêter à la place de la justice et de
police moi je viens avec les matériaux
de la liberté d'expression et notamment
de ceux qui ont capté je vous dis ça
vous répondez quoi je vais vous répondre
de façon très précise d'abord la
question qui sont mes actionnaires
la société éditrice de l'opinion
s'appelle b médias presse et internet
l'actionnaire de b médias presse et
internet c'est une holding qui s'appelle
des médias elle est actionnaire à 100%
et donc la loi française
exige de révéler les actionnaires de la
société éditrice
je vous le redis l'actionnaire de b
médias presse et internet et donc de
l'opinion c'est very dia pourquoi est ce
que je vous dis ça d'abord pour vous
pour me permettre de faire un petit
détour avec un des épisodes qui a failli
nous faire mourir qui a été directement
drivée par le gouvernement socialiste de
l'époque qui
voyaient d'un mauvais oeil notre survie
pour dire les choses simplement
en 2013 il y avait une disposition
fiscale qui vient d'être
renouvelé au cours de la loi de finances
2022 dispositions fiscales qui
permettait à tout actionnaires personnes
physiques ou personnel qui investit dans
un journal de presse d'information
générale qui permettait donc de déduire
de son investissement la valeur 25 % de
la valeur de son investissement du
montant de ses impôts
dispositions fiscales très intéressante
et qui pouvaient intéresser nos
actionnaires on s'est donc intéressé on
s'est donc intéressé à ça pour essayer
de voir si on pouvait en profiter pour
capitaliser notre société se développer
plus vite
on a demandé à l'administration un
rescrit la réponse a été non vous n'y
avez pas droit et la raison pour
laquelle nous n'y avions pas droit et la
suivante l'administration nous dit vous
avez levé de l'argent au niveau de ce
qu'ils ont appelé la holding c'est à
dire des médias la société qui exploite
qu'il ya une filiale qui est l'éditrice
des médias et la société qui a une
filiale éditrice et la niçoise on me dit
si vous aviez lever l'argent au niveau
de la filiale alors vous auriez eu droit
mais puisque vous avez levé l'argent aux
niveaux d'eau dessus vous n'y avez pas
droit et donc passez votre chemin
discussion en discussion je fais
remarquer que la loi de façon très
précise dit toute société exploitant un
journal était de faire un peuple a droit
à une
cet avantage fiscal la migration balaye
pas d'un revers de la main je vais
devant le tribunal administratif de
paris qui me donnent raison
l'administration fait appel je nous
allons devant la cour d'appel
administrative de paris qui me donnent
raison l'administration va au conseil
d'état le conseil d'état me donne raison
et en plus condamne
l'état aux dépens pourquoi est ce que je
vous raconte ça parce que c'est
important de faire la distinction dans
les sujets qui vous intéressent monsieur
le rapporteur entre une société éditrice
et la société qui exploite aujourd'hui
le droit français
prend en compte essentiellement la
notion de société éditrice et donc la
société éditrice de l'opinion c'est des
médias presse et internet
et donc en conformité avec le droit j'ai
donné la possibilité à mes actionnaires
j'ai répondu positivement à certains
actionnaires qui ne souhaitait pas au
début être révélée parce qu'ils
craignaient
que leur présence dans un média réputé
libéral soit conçu comme on va dire une
forme d'agression politique vis-à-vis du
pouvoir présents je vous le redis j'ai
passé quelques nuits blanches à
comprendre que le pouvoir de l'époque ne
souhaitait pas que nous vivions et ses
actionnaires la ne souhaitait pas être
les entre guillemets victimes
collatérales de ce que nous étions bons
le évidemment et vous l'avez dit à
l'instant je suis rapporteur tous ses
actionnaires ont été petit à petit connu
vous en oubliez un qui sait lui marc est
venu lui-même révélé c'est claude
perdriel qui a été un actionnaire dès le
démarrage de de notre aventure mais ce
qui est important c'est de comprendre
que tous ces gens là sont venus sur une
aventure
avec une orientation libérale vous
l'avez dit monsieur le président dès
l'origine et ont eues on voulu être
protégés des dégâts politiques que ça
pouvait leur causer tout ça est un peu
derrière nous et je réponds bah par
votre question sur l'indépendance dans
le pacte d'actionnaires que tous ces
actionnaires ont signé il y à une
disposition particulière qui me donne à
moi la majorité absolue sur toutes les
questions d'ordre éditorial tout sujet
éditoriale est un sujet sur lequel je
suis systématiquement et sans discussion
possible majoritaire donc le contenu du
journal la manière dont on fait nos
choix la ligne éditoriale le choix des
journalistes tout ce qui relève du
contenu je suis majoritaire pour le
reste la grande différence entre les
médias dont vous avez abondamment parlé
et dont vous avez
et reçu les propriétaires et la modeste
aventure que je mène c'est que au
capital de l'opinion il y à un grand
nombre de médias de milliardaires et
ceux ci se surveillent et au fond se
neutralisent les uns les autres et cette
présence d'un grand nombre
d'actionnaires très puissant me donne
une extraordinaire liberté je finis d'un
mot en vous disant qu'
il n'y a pas de de lancement de
l'entreprise
d'une envergure réelles sans faire appel
à des gens qui ont de l'argent ça
n'existe pas
et du clown elle veut vous a raconté
tout à l'heure que il avait
mediapart aujourd'hui et est une
entreprise qui vivait sans actionnaire
pardon mai et d'août enel a fait appel à
des fortunes les grandes fortunes je
suis unir sur ce point j'ai une question
à qui vous concerne les grandes fortunes
pour lancer son média est donc
naturel d'ailleurs très bien il a fait
appel à des gens qui on est et qui sont
extrêmement riches et qui ont mis de
l'argent dans son média de manière à ce
qu ensuite il devait y avoir très bien
bon voila moi je pense avoir répondu sur
la question et je vais juste venir dans
le prolongement de cette question moi je
veux vraiment que des fois il ya des
réponses à des questions et qu'on ne
sait pas autre chose à chaque fois j'ai
posé une question qui est est ce que il
ya eu parce que j'ai lu pas mal de
papiers et j'ai moi même regardez
en nombre et en quantité d'articles sur
les uns sur les autres ca c
mon propre travail
je vous ai dit deux choses
du quasi publi-rédactionnel parfois vous
accuse sur des activités liées à la
shoah d'autres
et puis on vous reproche de favoriser
votre actionnaire important par rapport
à des concurrents dans le traitement
même de l'information les concernant
vous pouvez me dire oui non mais dites
moi réputé d'abord je vous dire que le
fait que vous qualifiez les les articles
d'un salon donne de joris de quasi plus
guère d'actionnaires elle me trouve par
et insultant pour l'heureux lors qu'elle
était professionnel mais c'est mon
commentaire à votre question après non
je refais je refuse de considérer que
nous avons un traitement particulier
plus favorable pour lvmh et un
traitement par le silence pour ses
concurrents moi je voudrais revenir sur
la question du financement de départ
vous l'avez abordé monsieur fottorino
elle est important que je crois donc l'
équilibre économique n'est n'est pas
trouvée parce que c'est vrai quand on
regarde vos 4 j'allais dire aventure
professionnelle
les quatre au départ font appel vous
corrigerez peut-être fottorino parce que
je n'ai pas trouvé l'information pour
vous concernant mais pour les trois
autres en tout cas les quatre au départ
font appel à des investisseurs qui sont
qui apportent de l'argent les gens qui
apportent de l'argent et qu'ils
apportent de manière importante pour
vous aider a lancé l'entreprise
pas citer tous monsieur b to a donné ces
indications concernant le l'opinion je
crois que madame roberts vous mais
monsieur niel et matthieu pigasse ont
apporté des financements pour encore une
fois monsieur fottorino j'ai pas trouvé
pour vous mais vous ne vous le dirais et
pour vous
monsieur plenel mediapart vous avez eu
au départ monsieur niel aussi pour deux
cent mille euros et puis
deux autres non mais vous répondre et
peut-être que si je me trompe vrais
problèmes et les six mois poser la
question et puis monsieur bouchard et
monsieur ville m qui ont apporté 500
mille euros chacun moi ma question est
simple c'est comment on peut monter je
dis bien lancée je ne dis pas une fois
que l'école équilibre économique et
trouver mais comment on peut lancer
aujourd'hui un média en france sans
faire appel à des investisseurs
qui sont généralement des investisseurs
qui ont de l'argent parce qu'ils ont
développé une activité économique une
société dans des secteurs divers et
variés mais qui les uns et les autres
concerneront des sujets que vous pouvez
traiter
oui je vais je vais vous et je vais vous
éclairer
d'ailleurs servent c'est un peu la suite
de ce que je disais tout à l'heure sur
le fait que c'est pas facile de trouver
une banque qui vous prête quand vous
voulez faire un média
il se trouve que ça a été une heureuse
rencontre
vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure
lorsque j'ai quitté le monde j'ai écrit
un livre s'appelle mon tour du monde où
j'ai raconté 25 ans de de journal et de
journalisme est un homme à lui seul il
s'appelait henry hermand il est mort
aujourd'hui
on était en 2013 et il avait participé à
l' aventure d'un journal dont on n'a pas
parlé depuis la bulle après midi parce
qu'il a disparu qu'était le matin de
paris
qui avait collaboré un certain nombre de
journaux et puis comme industrielle
avait réussi dans sa partie qui était
l'immobilier commercial est cet homme
m'a dit est ce que vous ne voulez pas
faire un journal je dis je ne sais pas
si je veux faire un journal mais en tout
cas j'ai pas les moyens de le faire même
si je le voulais mais dit si vous avez
une idée moi je peux vous aider
donc avant sa mort puisqu'il est mort
dix huit mois après le lancement
il a fait ce qu'on appelle l'amorçage
c'est à dire que il nous a on a fait un
budget tous les trois mois c'était assez
artisanal et de trois mois en trois mois
on a pu lancer le 1 et le développer il
est décédé nous avons comme je les dis
une 60% du capital
le reste sont des actionnaires
minoritaires c'est sa famille en fait
ces enfants et donc nous sommes tout à
fait libre de tous nos mouvements
éditoriaux il ya même pas de clause
c'est nous qui décidons ce qu'elles ont
j'assiste qu'une seconde sur on est
clairement parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé
lui à la fois comme ami de michel rocard
et en effet quand j'ai rencontré henry
hermand je me suis rendu compte qu'il
était un compagnon de route d'un demi
siècle avec avec michel rocard et plus
tard il a été un de ceux qui ont soutenu
emmanuel macron
je précise cela parce que quelquefois on
dit ah oui c'est un journal macro nist
il faut pas être trop comment dire
trop naïf sur le fait que lorsqu'on fait
un journal avec un actionnaire qui se
révèle être un soutien d'un futur
président de la république
évidemment cet actionnaire a envie que
vous parliez de son poulain
et ça a été pour nous des discussions
assez franche et je lui ai dit non je ne
fais pas un journal de d'emmanuel macro
mais il faut pas faire d' anachronisme
on était en 2013 2014 ont été un moment
donné ou qui aurait prédit qu'ils
deviendraient atteindre la république
mais effectivement et c'est bien
l'occasion de le dire
engagement qu'avait henry hermand
jusqu'à sa mort parce qu'il est mort
2016 était aux côtés de deux ce futur
candidat qui était macron pour autant
ceux qui lisent attentivement le 1
savent qu'à la fois j'ai eu souvent des
entretiens intéressant et important avec
le futur chef de l'état lorsqu'il était
notamment muni de l'économie à bercy où
il a théorisé la place du roi dans nos
institutions c'est un entretien qui a
été souvent repris
et que d'autre part il ya eu des numéros
du un très très sévère sur la politique
à la fois économique sociale des manuels
mâcon donc ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'à aucun moment je ne me suis mis une
laisse autour du cou avec cette origine
mais
mais j'aurais beaucoup aimé que ce soit
des investisseurs j'allais dire
complètement neutres qu'ils puissent
m'aider à mettre en route cette idée
mais si monsieur herman n'avait pas été
là je pense pas que j'aurais jamais eu
les moyens de lancer le vent merci à
l'abri sur monsieur plenel qui
[Musique]
alors vous avez raison monsieur le
président on ne lance pas un média sans
argent
et on ne lance pas un média indépendant
non plus sans argent
nous pour vous expliquer la manière nous
nous sommes construits on a passé une
année à
qui est l année 2015 à construire les
jours que ce soit d'un point de vue
technique éditorial ou financiers et on
la construit brique par brique est la
première de ces briques ça a été de
faire appel aux lecteurs donc on a fait
un carton ding un financement
participatif nous a permis de lever
85000 euros ça c'était la première
brique de notre financement et surtout
ça nous a permis de construire une
communauté de lecteurs
qui sont devenus ensuite nos abonnés
et parallèlement à ça ça nous a permis
d'aller voir des investisseurs privés en
dix ans voyez on a déjà sept communautés
de futurs abonnés autour de nous vous
pouvez nous faire confiance et investir
et sur la question de l'indépendance
bien sûr par rapport à ses actionnaires
privés nous pour vous expliquer notre
capital aujourd'hui les cofondateurs des
jours on 69% du capital donc l'énorme
majorité
le deuxième actionnaire des jours sont
les lecteurs
à peu près 10% un tout petit peu moins
de 10% et ensuite on a une dizaine
d'investisseurs privés dont xavier niel
vous l'avez vous l'avez site est
effectivement à des tout petits
pourcentages donc la réponse à la caisse
comment
oui pas que 1 et d'ailleurs
et d'ailleurs c'est important ce que
vous dites c'est pas caché chez nous
c'est dans une page qui est gratuite qui
est ouverte à tout le monde c'est très
important pour la confiance avec des
lecteurs d'être transparente sur ces
questions là
et donc notre actionnariat déjà et des
contrôles et en immense majorité par
nous les actionnaires privés sont à des
tout petits pourcentages et ensuite
dans nos statuts mais ça c'était en
accord avec les actionnaires que nous
sommes allés voir
ils n'ont ils ne siègent dans aucune
instance des jours aucune donc qu'en
fait concrètement le nord l'est comme
n'ont aucune instance déjouera par l'ag
annuelle logiquement merci monsieur
plenel sur ce point on aborde d'autres
sujets
ce point illustre la question du
libéralisme sommes-nous un pays libéral
et sommes-nous une démocratie vivante
d'un point de vue anglo saxons c'est à
dire de libéralisme économique compensé
par un libéralisme politique de respect
d'indépendance des contre-pouvoirs nous
ne sommes pas un pays libéral quand nous
avons voulu fonder mediapart je pensais
que nous trouverions sans problème des
personnes voulant qu'il ya une presse
indépendante qui comprit dérange leurs
intérêts
ces gens là n'existe pas en france
au sens de puissance économique
véritable vous savez très bien quelle
est la recette de mediapart un
journaliste d'intérêt public qui peut
déranger un jour la droite un jour la
gauche le monde des affaires des partis
politiques un journalisme au service du
droit de savoir des citoyens
j'insiste sur cette question parce que
c'est le coeur du sujet si le
libéralisme économique c'est simplement
la rapacité économique
accompagnée de brutalité démocratique ce
n'est pas du libéralisme
c'est ce qu'ils font des démocraties
autorités ou le monde des affaires fait
ce qu'il veut et y compris à baisser les
contre-pouvoirs que sont la presse en
l'occurrence pour mediapart en 2007 le
financement participatif en ligne
n'existait pas
le premier financement de mediapart
c'est l'endettement des fondateurs
nous nous sommes endettés
pour un montant d'un peu plus d'un
million d'euros
et j'ai remboursé pour ma part pendant
dix ans un emprunt personnel
sur le choix qui a été fait de s'engager
sur médiapart il n'est pas question de
trouver des financements complémentaires
sans prendre nous mêmes notre risque
c'est le fait d'avoir pris nous mêmes
notre risque qui a permis à deux
exceptions dans ce paysage qui ne sont
pas très connus qui sont jean louis
bouchard et thierry wilhem que vous avez
cités qui ont accepté de nous
accompagner
troisièmement nous avons accompagné sa
d'une société des amis avec 87
contributeurs et là je voudrais
rectifier ce bouteillon qui est montée
jusqu'au président de la république lors
de notre entretien de 2018 non xavier
niel n'a jamais été actionnaire direct
mediapart il a été un des 87 donateurs
de la société des amis de médiapart
présidée par le mathématicien michel
broué et il a été à une époque où il
n'était pas du tout l'oligarque qu'il
est devenu où il était simplement un
fournisseur d'accès internet et n'ayant
pas la cession de free enfin
quatrièmement une fois fait cet amorçage
comme a dit ma consoeur des jours
la recette du financement ce sont les
abonnés
et l'essentiel pour nous c'était
d'atteindre le point d'équilibré et à
partir de ce point équilibre le point
d'équilibré nous avons ramassé trois
millions et demi d'euros pour partir en
2008 et nous avons atteint le point
d'équilibré deux ans et demi après à la
fin de l'année 2010
le point d'équilibré nous l'avons
atteint à 40 mille abonnés dans la
foulée de la sphère des temps courts et
dans la suite nous avons veillé à la
bonne gestion et à la rentabilité de
cette entreprise avec un objectif qui
était qui était
celui de départ
qui était de
[Musique]
d'inventer un modèle vertueux qui est
celui que nous avons mis cinq ans à
inventer dans le cadre des fonds de
dotation de ce fonds pour une presse
libre qui sanctuarise donc
mediapart la conséquence de cela c'est
que médiapart s'est endettée s'est
endetté pour racheter l'ensemble de ses
actionnaires qui donc ne sont plus
actionnaire de mediapart l'actionnaire
c'est une société pour la protection de
l'indépendance de mediapart qui elle
même est contrôlé par le fonds pour une
presse libre en l'occurrence pour
terminer la question le il ya un point
commun entre nous quatre quelles que
soient les différences de sensibilité et
de modèles vous avez devant vous des
journaux ou des médias de journalistes
de journalistes créé par des
journalistes défendant avec leurs
nuances et leurs différences de chemin
le métier de journaliste la cohérence de
ce métier autour du service du public
autour de la vérité des fêtes et quelles
que soient nos divergences avec nicolas
bour tout je sais combien il y à
d'excellents journalistes à l'opinion
donc voilà notre point commun le sujet
qui vous occupez c'est pour ça que
pardon monsieur le président j'ai été un
peu vifs tout à l'heure le sujet qui
vous ouvrent cupe c'est de se dire nous
nous sommes des exceptions aujourd'hui
l'ensemble majoritaire du paysage
médiatique
ce ne sont plus des médias de
journalistes les directeurs de
publication nous en plus des
journalistes le directeur de publication
je le fais j'étais encore au tribunal de
foix cette semaine il rend compte des
contenus c'est lui qui dans la loi de
1881 et comptable des contenus c'est un
journaliste dans nos médias c'est un
journaliste dont les autres ce ne sont
plus ce sont des gens liés à ces milieux
d'affaires et donc la question qui vous
est posée nous nos modèles sont vertueux
mais la question qui vous est posée
c'est comment vous recréez pour
reprendre une formule libéral au sens
véritable du terme le mur
the wall on disait ça traditionnellement
à l'égard de
l'immersion de des intrusions de la
publicité dans le contenu éditorial mais
comment vous faites le mur par rapport à
cette presse d'industrie qui intervient
dans les médias et nous sommes bien
placés pour le savoir pour que les
informations qui la dérange ou qui
dérange ses intérêts ou qui les rend sa
clientèle ou qui dérange sa clientèle
politique ou partisane ne soit plus
répercuter dans ses médias
et s'éteint c'est une vraie question
pour vous tous un jour ou l'autre ça
vous concernera quel que soit votre
sensibilité le fait qu'une information
soit en tête de gondole comme ça a été
dit soit dans la hiérarchie des
informations soit dans les aides lines
dans la manchette c'est là la vitalité
d'une démocratie et combien de fois nous
mediapart sommes témoins d'information
d'importance d'ampleur et qui ne sont
pas anecdotiques et qui mettent un temps
fou un temps fou à parvenir dans
l'espace public si je peux me permettre
un dernier mot monsieur dernier mot
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de jeux lontan
ses derniers mots je vous recommande de
ce point de vue à partir du 15 février
show mediapart mais surtout du 16
février en salles de cinéma à aller voir
un film que nous produisons et réalisons
avec l' agence première ligne qui fait
cash investigations que mediapart et
première ligne vont sortir le 16 février
et en salles dans toute la france ça
s'appelle médias crash sous-titré qui a
tué le débat public c'est au coeur de
votre sujet je vous le recommande merci
ce qui nous intéresse cet après-midi
comprenez bien c'est de comprendre vos
modèles qui sont atypiques par rapport
aux autres os mais qui sont aussi une
des spécificités de des médias française
pour ça que je vous invite à revenir à
chaque fois sur vos modèles parce que il
nous intéresse aussi de sebring jean
raymond gionet
merci président bonjour madame et
messieurs
puisque le pluralisme est le maître mot
de notre commission denquête
nous sommes et je suis particulièrement
heureux de vous auditionné cet après
midi alors que nous vivons une séquence
est encore la semaine prochaine
d'un défilé de stars du cac 40 et vous
même tous les cadres dans vos
différences et votre parcours en
attestent vous êtes des personnalités
qui ne laisse pas indifférente et dans
ce monde monotone et monocorde
ça a quelque chose de particulièrement
stimulant le sujet dont on traite
est vieux comme le monde monsieur plenel
et monsieur fottorino l'on dit tout à
l'heure historiquement avec brio
très modestement et sans remonter à
bailly le rapport lancelot 2005 n'est
pas si ancien que ça à la commande de
jean pierre raffarin à l'époque premier
ministre voilà c'est un rapport de plus
de la république française qui est très
intéressant en revanche et nous revoilà
pencher sur
l'expression sur un marronnier qui selon
la vie démocratique de notre pays prend
plus ou moins d'ampleur et vous l'avez
dit vous l'avez souligné tous les quatre
là comment dire la verticalité
maintenant
donne un sentiment de force encore plus
décuplée alors
j'ai 3 3 questions relativement simple
et elle s'adresse à tous les quatre ceux
et celles qui voudront y répondre seront
les bienvenus nous avons en france une
presse d'opinion
subventionné vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur plenel et vous avez même montré
le mécanisme qui fait que les grandes
puissances économiques
arrive à tirer profit de cet argent qui
est un argent public donc notre argent
de contribuables
c'est comme ça
c'est en france sont
voilà c'est une spécificité mais en tout
cas c'est comme ça l'audiovisuel lui a
cela de particulier c'est que puisqu'il
fait appel à des fréquences pour être
diffusées il devient un bien public et à
ce moment là il ya des autorisations et
il n'ya pas
d'audiovisuel d'opinion
ma question faut-il en arriver
justement un audiovisuel
d'opinion sachant que personne n'a le
fusil sur la tempe pour regarder qu'il
s'y news qui lci qu' france info
et à ce moment là dans cette question et
contenus aussi le devenir pour vous
alors qu'il est sur la sellette et on
peut le comprendre est-ce que
l'audiovisuel public lui aussi financé
de façon très importante
3 milliards 7 je le rappelle au budget
est-ce que lui à ce moment là ne peut
pas jouer ce rôle
d'audiovisuel totalement indépendant
puisque vous savez qu'il est sous le feu
de la critique aussi quelles que soient
les sensibilités mais on l'accuse de
rouler plutôt à gauche
la deuxième question et à l'heure où les
influenceurs sont portées au rang de
star dans la consommation
comment est il possible d'empêcher des
capitaines d'industrie d'obtenir de l'
influence plus que tous le mot a été
rappelé plusieurs fois de l' influence
par l'intermédiaire des médias je prends
juste une image pour
bien faire comprendre mon propos voilà
deux pour ceux qui s'intéressent à la
formule 1 depuis la nuit des temps les
règlements essaye de contraindre voilà
et par chance j'allais dire ne voyez pas
là un côté malin dans ma réflexion mais
on a une profusion d'ingénieurs qui dont
c'est le métier qui contourne
adroitement les règlements de plus en
plus compliqué j'ai bien peur qu'on en
soit là est ce qu'il ya à votre avis un
chemin pour cela et enfin ma dernière
question ne vaut-il pas mieux favoriser
l'avènement et je reprends ce qu'a dit
monsieur b tout ce qui a été aussi
soulignée par monsieur fottorino et et
j'aime bien quand il dit retrouvez l'âge
d'or du journalisme avec le les grandes
références est-ce qu'il ne voudrait pas
mieux justement trouver un mécanisme
permettant de favoriser l'émergence et
vous êtes la preuve vivante que le
pluralisme est quand même je peux pas me
résoudre monsieur plenel à ce que notre
pays soit un petit peu caricaturé comme
étant un pays une dictature voyez ce que
je veux dire bon mais mellil libéralisme
là je partage -
en revanche croyait bien que avant de
travailler sur un sujet j'en termine là
monsieur le président avant de
travailler sur un sujet ici on le
travaille
moi je pour m'informer j'ai plusieurs
canaux bien évidemment j'ai lu vos deux
articles sur nos commissions la
réception de ce boulot rit de monsieur
arnaud indépendamment du talent
d'écriture quand je dis votre c'est
médiapart vous avez eu la dent très très
dur je peux le concevoir mais concevez
aussi qu'ici nous sommes dans une maison
où il ya aussi une rigueur nous ne
sommes pas nous nous roulons pour
personne et je crois que la pluralité
autour de cette table en attestent nous
faisons notre travail et je trouve que
là vous avez eu la dent un peu dur ce
que je vous propose mes chers collègues
c'est de regrouper les questions parce
que le temps passe et comme c'est une
table ronde vous êtes nombreux
autour de la table
j'avais invité michel logis déjà à
compléter la série de questions merci
monsieur le président madame messieurs
alors je vais fait robe très court alors
je vais directement aux questions c'est
peut-être style journalistique qui peut
être qu'il va peut-être vous convenez je
vais demander monsieur blé mesurer deux
compléments de pardon ce que vous avez
dit
combien de journalistes travaillent
aujourd'hui pour médiapart parce que
vous ai donné quelques chiffres et je
veux savoir le nombre exact et
j'aimerais aussi connaître
sur quels critères voulait recruter sa
cb mais le complément d'information il
vous a parlé aussi d'un fonds
d'investissement c'est bien ça c'est
bien compris vous avez un fond
aujourd'hui qui est à la tête si le ce a
parlé d'un fonds
de dotation mais eux qui aujourd'hui à
des participations aussi dans d'autres
médias n'ont aucun parce que sinon je
pensais que ont commencé là aussi un
début de concentration est ce que je
veux dire alors pour revenir de manière
beaucoup plus globale au nez on est
gamin dans un monde qui évolue
énormément et vous l'avez cité mais je
pense que de manière assez significative
c'est aujourd'hui la part prépondérante
des grands réseaux des grandes
plateformes internationales ont parlé de
la presse la bresse a perdu 50% de
s'appeler vis des ses revenus
publicitaires en dix ans donc et qui ont
été captées non pas par d'autres meteab
et surtout par les grandes plateformes
donc là on est vraiment en pleine en
pleine évolution et je voulais justement
savoir
si les concentrations
dont certains d'entre vous on
indiqué que c'était que c'était des
choses qu'il fallait éviter est-ce que
des concentrations n'ont pas permis de
sauver certains médias aussi aussi que
honnête jusqu'au bout il n'y a pas que
le côté négatif on peut y avoir aussi un
côté positif dans la concentration
et puis j'aimerais savoir aussi parce
que jean raymond il a parlé de du visuel
voulez savoir aussi de douzevielle
public si pour vous
vous estimez que c'est le modèle de
idéal de pluralisme et d'indépendance
journalistique et puis pour terminer
je voulais savoir en quoi vous incarnez
ici aujourd'hui la liberté d'expression
par rapport aux autres médias
merci
sylvie robert je vous laisserai répondre
merci monsieur le président madame
messieurs alors c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas
le temps et monsieur plenel a tenu à
rappeler l'objectif de notre commission
denquête si on avait le temps je
voudrais aussi lui dire que ce qui est
important pour nous c'est de parler
aussi de la qualité de l'information et
quand je vois tous les cas tu es
connaissant le travail que vous faites
je pense aux uns parfois j'ai
l'impression d'être même sur de la
littérature va quand je lis le 1 donc la
spécificité là la qualité
et je dirais dans ce monde complexe de
la fabrique de l'information c'est aussi
un sujet
par rapport aux chaînes d'info en
continu etc donc on pourrait disserter
longtemps mais ce que je voulais dire
par là c'est que on peut parler aussi de
l'évolution des usages comment demain on
va lire l'information comment
aujourd'hui les générations s'empare de
cette question là on a parlé des modèles
économiques j'y reviendrai pas on a
parlé de l'organisation et de la con la
gouvernance ce que je voulais vous dire
c'est que tout se tient et bien sûr il
ya les questions vous l'avez dit
d'interférences les questions que qu'a
posée le rapporteur
mais je pense qu'on est on se doit en
tout cas nous en tant que parlementaire
d'avoir aussi une vision un peu plus
globale des choses pour un moment
pouvoir légiférer j'arrive à mes deux
questions puisque il ya quand même des
dispositifs législatifs derrière qu'on
aurait envie de faire évoluer voire même
de réformer alors on a beaucoup parlé la
loi 86 vous avez parlé du statut
juridique des rédactions vous avez
effectivement également parlé des aides
à la presse est ce que pour vous il y à
d'autres dispositifs qu'on pourra
imaginer pour en tout cas garante pire
ce pluralisme parce que en tout cas on
est tous d'accord que notre commission
accc est d' enquête traite d'un sujet
démocratique et c'est ça en tout cas qui
nous rassemble donc y at il d'autres
dispositifs à la fois aussi pour rendre
viable la presse indépendante ça c'est
ma première question est la deuxième on
n'a pas de l'audiovisuel est ce que vous
considérez que l'art comme ex csa joue
suffisamment son rôle ou en tout cas les
outils pour aujourd'hui garantir en tout
cas mettre en oeuvre les missions qui
lui sont confiées
je tombe dans le sénateur capo canellas
on va déjà répondre à ces questions puis
fera une deuxième série après demandé
d'y répondre peut-être pas tous chacun
parce que sinon on est parti pour deux
heures ne serait ce que pour ses
réponses mais parmi les huit questions
qui ont été posées si vous voulez vous
positionner sur une ou plusieurs
réponses n'hésitez pas je ne sais pas
qui commence
je viens commencé sur les tout-petits
levé
sur l'action et subventions presse
d'opinion subventionné est-ce que
l'audiovisuel public peut devenir à
maîtriser le public d'opinion
d'abord je voudrais rappeler que les
subventions actuelles qui sont versés à
la presse est en tout cas à la presse
papier sont pour la majorité des sommes
versées à la presse re router
directement faire presstalis autrement
dit les sommes qui sont
qui apparaissent dans les tableaux comme
étant des aides directes à la presse
sont des sommes qui sont directement
reversés par les journaux à presstalis
et c'est tellement vrai que la veille du
jour où nous recevons ces aides nous
recevons un courrier du directeur
général de la dg milk qui nous demande
de nous engager sur l'honneur à reverser
immédiatement ces sommes pourquoi parce
que ces sommes sont destinées sont sont
liées au plan de sauvetage de presstalis
et pourquoi est ce qu'elle passe par les
médias parce que si elle allait
directement à presstalis elles seraient
considérés comme des aides d'état et
condamné par bruxelles
donc je vous engage à regarder ces
chiffres avec beaucoup de précaution on
est assez loin des sommes qui sont en
général évoqué
sur la subvention de la
regarder une presse audiovisuelle
d'opinion moi j'aime bien gras peut-être
de répondre à la question sur l'art
comme moi j'ai une vision
assez disons iconoclaste ou en tout cas
peut-être pas forcément partagée de ses
affaires de télévision je pense que
désormais comme il y à un grand nombre
de chaînes sur lesquelles on peut
s'informer
auxquels il faut ajouter tous les moyens
de s'informer
en direct soit par sur la vidéo en tout
cas en streaming
moi je considère que
le sujet des temps de parole est un
sujet qui est désormais obsolète pas
forcément pendant les campagnes
électorales active mais le l'idée du
temps de parole et est une idée qui me
paraît encore une fois obsolète il y a
aujourd'hui c'est lorsqu'il y avait une
deux trois chaînes
qui était du service public il était de
l'intérêt public que ce ces temps de
parole soit équilibré aujourd'hui qu'il
y a un nombre important de chaînes
d'information plus encore une fois la
capacité à s'informer un peu partout on
n'a pas cité par exemple ces nouveaux
médias quelques qui sont
extraordinairement
populaire dans une partie de la
population je pense à brut
brut est un média qui a eu une ligne
éditoriale qui n'a que faire de l'
équilibre de des opinions qui se fiche
complètement de savoir s'ils sont plus
ceux ci oublient cela ils ont une ligne
éditoriale ils sont libres de l'ap de la
portée est davantage et danse dans ce
paysage qui est maintenant multiples et
encore une fois hors période électorale
où on a besoin d'une égalité
démocratique je considère que
la règle de temps de parole est obsolète
et surarmés et donc est ce que l'art
comme dans ce contexte pourrait
consacrer sa force à autre chose ce
serait une possibilité qui sera sûrement
bienvenus
la banque verte
alors ne serais pas étonné que je sois
totalement en désaccord qu'est ce qui
vient d'être dit
il ya une chaîne aujourd'hui qui est
devenue une chaîne d'opinion vous avez
eu vous avez eu l'occasion d'en parler
avec avec vincent bolloré cette semaine
ses news alors il a nié un je rappelle
quand même le slogan de ses new skies et
venez avec vos convictions vous ferez
une opinion donc en fait c'est
revendiqué jusque jusque dans le slogan
et dans les publicités
donc non je ne pense pas qu'il faille
que les chaînes de télé deviennent des
chaînes d'opinion et et je pense même
que le temps de parole
moi je pense que ce n'est pas du tout
obsolète et même que ça devrait être
renforcée parce que le grand problème
avec ces news un qui est un cas d'école
c'est que la petite musique
quelques elle fait entendre elle ne
passe pas seulement par par les invités
politiques parce que là ils sont plus ou
moins obligés de respecter alors ils
essayent ils essaient de passer outre
notamment lors des régionales en juin
dernier où ils sont malencontreusement
oublié une heure de rn dans leur
déclaration csa
mais ils sont peu ou prou obligé avec
des astuces sont les passants dans la
nuit dont là aussi sont fait taper sur
les doigts ou ou en faisant des espèces
de petits ce qu'ils appellent des apps
politique où ils vont ils vont
refourguer tout toute l'opposition et la
majorité d'ailleurs pour pour équilibrer
le temps de parole malgré tout ils sont
obligés de respecter mais ça passe
surtout par
une
catégorie de que j'appellerai les
invités permanents et qui ne sont plus
des invités en fait qu'ils sont des
chroniqueurs à tel point qu'ils sont
payés
monsieur bodeur que vous avez auditionné
l'a dit d'ailleurs
et ces personnes sont payées je pense
aujourd'hui un exemple très précis qui
est jean messia
gens mais ça aujourd'hui porte parole
d'eric zemmour et jean messia est un
invité obligé de ses news à la demande
du patron de seignosse serge nadjar
quatre fois par semaine alors j'ose
espérer qu'ils vont qui vont arrêter de
l'inviter quatre fois par semaine mais
mais les idées les opinions elle passe
aussi par par ces personnes là les
invités permanents sur ces news c'est
aussi charlotte dans hélas de valeurs
actuelles ce sont des gens de boulevard
voltaire de causeur voilà donc moi je
pense qu'au contraire il faut renforcer
les pouvoirs du csa parce que il ya
beaucoup de fantasmes autour du csa qui
passe parfois pour un super censeurs et
parfois pour trop mou selon selon les
opinions
le csa ce qu'ils font c'est qu'ils
appliquent la loi voilà tout simplement
mais avant d'appliquer la loi comme vous
le savez il ya tout un arsenal de
riposte graduée
qui peuvent aller jusqu'à
couper en fait l'antenne à une télé qui
n'auraient pas respecté ses obligations
et ce système là
fait qu'aujourd'hui très souvent le csa
paraît trop mou et pourtant
ils ont pris des décisions assez fortin
sur ces news notamment quand ils ont mis
de son 1000 euros damende à ces news sur
les propos d'eric zemmour sur les
mineurs isolés pour lesquels il a été
condamné par la justice cette fois cette
semaine
donc je pense qu'il faudrait que le rôle
du csa art comme aujourd'hui soit soit
clarifiée qu'elle est d'aider des outils
plus clair et pour ça on en revient
toujours un changement de la loi de
naturellement
monsieur fottorino
[Musique]
je ne suis pas spécialement compétents
sur les question de télévision mais je
suis un citoyen en rouge espère attentif
et ce qui est problématique
aujourd'hui c'est de voir effectivement
un
propriétaire comme comme vincent bolloré
feindre d'être complètement étranger aux
contenus de ses antennes
à l'identité de ses chroniqueurs en
particulier d'eric zemmour qui est
maintenant candidat à la présidence de
la république
donc de nous prendre pour des imbéciles
et ça il n'y a pas besoin d'être très
spécialistes pour s'en rendre compte
de ce point de vue là je pense que il
est aussi problématique de voir que
lorsque ce candidat n'est pas à
l'antenne il y est quand même il est
quand même à travers différents
chroniqueurs différents animateurs et
donc on entretient on reprend ses propos
et c'est
donc de la même manière je pense que il
faut du pluralisme au sein des chaînes
que soit le service public que ce soit
des chaînes privées
mais je crois qu'il est dangereux de
laisser non seulement un temps de parole
parce que je serais peut-être moins pas
plus prudent que nicolas beytout sur sur
ce point je pense quand même que le
temps de parole c'est du temps aussi de
propagande quelquefois et de
désinformation
et ça c'est très important de veiller à
ça c'est pas eux quand je chante en éric
des mots je n'entends pas de
l'information je n'entend même pas une
tentative d' éclairer les esprits des
citoyens j'entends vraiment delà de la
propagande de bas étage donc le csa plus
le contrôleur aura des moyens plus y
sera vigilant et plus
la démocratie notre démocratie élective
son trouvera renforcée maintenant je
voudrais attraper au vol deux ou trois
questions que j'ai entendu paye qui
m'ont fait réagir la concentration at
elle sauvé des médias ça c'est une
question c'est une question parce que
effectivement dans notre métier on
apprend on n'est pas des yeux des juges
qui instruisent à charge ou à décharge
mais on doit avoir
précisément ce goût de la nuance ce good
du fait que quelquefois une information
qui nous paraît une réalité qui nous
paraît tellement fort dans un sens il
faut essayer d'aller voir s'il n'y a pas
des éléments dans l'autre sens est ce
que vous dites c'est tres est votre
question sur la concentration at elle
sauvé les médias je crois qu'il faut
quand même qu'on dise une chose
importante à mes yeux
c'est que beaucoup de ces journaux qui
ont été rachetées dans les années 70 80
et plus tard ils ont été très contents
de trouver ses actionnaires ils sont
même qu'il faut aller les chercher
donc je pense que on peut leur prêter
après tout les intentions et je pense
qu'il faut les leur prêter mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que ça pose un vrai
problème à nous pour le coup à nous
journalistes
c'est que chacun d'entre nous a montré
que à notre petit niveau
on n'est pas des mastodontes on a
inventé quelque chose qui a l'heur de
plaire un certain nombre de lecteurs qui
nous font vivre qui font que on a une
relation directe avec eux mais je pense
que si tous ces médias ont peut être
racheté ces dernières années c'est que
globalement les grands journaux les
grands médias n'avaient pas trouver un
modèle économique viable
qui leur permettaient précisément de
dire à des actionnaires potentiels
passez votre chemin
alors la concentration il faut voir de
quoi on parle à une époque monsieur r
sens il a regroupé figaro et l'aurore et
c'était le tour ils pouvaient contourner
comme ça les lois il a regroupé des
journaux départementaux et hop ça ne
faisait plus qu'un donc on voyait bien
que c'était une manière de contourner la
loi sur les concentrations mais la
réalité c'était que ces journaux était
en train de mourir donc
quand il se passe le dépôt de bilan de
france antilles où les difficultés de
france antilles on voit monsieur niel
qui apparaît comme un comme un sauveur
comme un chevalier blanc on a vu bernard
tapie en provence à une époque et c'est
quand les journaux ont des difficultés
et qui vont chercher des repreneurs
ces repreneurs évidemment s'arroge des
droits qui ne devrait probablement pas
avoir des prérogatives mais il faut pas
oublier pour le danser le tango il faut
être deux c'est que très souvent des
journaux des médias ont été rachetés par
ce que il ne me serait mort sinon donc
pour répondre à votre question monsieur
laugier oui je considère que alors on
appelle sa concentration si on veut
parce qu'effectivement c'est d'un des
stratégies de concentration mais
beaucoup de médias seraient morts s'il
n'avait pas trouvé des investisseurs
pour venir les soutenir deux derniers
points que que j'ai relevées pour pour
répondre comment va-t-on lire
l'information demain madame robert ça je
pense que là aussi on est au coeur de
notre métier j'allais dire qu'est ce que
c'est qu'une information aujourd'hui
alors qu' aucun consensus même sur les
faits même les faits on dit qu'il ya
d'autres faits qui sont les mêmes faits
donc si vous voulez à partir de là pour
moi je pense que tout commence oui vous
savez que je fais du vélo beaucoup de ça
on met un casque très jeune pour se
protéger la tête on en a qu'une mais je
pense qu'il faut quand on met un casque
aux jeunes un casque d'information un
quinze qui leur permettent de se
protéger contre toutes les
désinformations qui vont entendre tout
au long de leur vie mais surtout au
moment où le cerveau est encore très
malléable donc si vous voulez pour moi
quand vous dites quel dispositif pour le
pluralisme comment lire l'information
pour moi c'est une tâche immense pour
lesquels il ya un avenir immense à
hauteur de l'enjeu qui est l'éducation
et je pense pas que ce soit bien sûr il
ya des heures d'éducation aux médias qui
sont passés de la seconde à la cinquième
c'est très bien mais je pense que c'est
rien par rapport à ce qui doit être fait
pour que précisément les jeunes et aussi
les profs parce que les professeurs du
coup soit mis en conformité avec ça moi
je discute souvent avec des professeurs
qui me disent maintenant il ya un
problème avec les textes l'ailé les gens
ne croient plus les textes qu'ils lisent
à parquer moment oui oui on en est là de
la remise en cause du savoir qu'est ce
que c'est que savoir c'est de la
compréhension et cesser de l'honnêteté
intellectuelle c'est de la bonne foi
celle inverse justement de ce qu'on
entend de ces tycoon aujourd'hui qu'ils
vous disent qu'ils connaissent pas
monsieur zemmour nissan même à peine
qu'il est sur leur chaîne wii donc entre
ça qui est qui est vraiment se du
monde et revenir à la base je pense
qu'effectivement c'est très important
que dès le début dès l'apprentissage du
savoir l'information soit au coeur aussi
bien qu'un programme d'histoire de maths
et de sciences et de vie de la terre
chez fennell
je remercie madame robert d'avoir
rappelé que derrière tout cet enjeu ya
la question de la qualité de
l'information
george orwell disait le premier ennemi
de la vérité n'est pas le mensonge ce
sont les convictions ce que nous
représentons ici ce n'est pas la
production d'opinion nous en avons tous
vous en avez tous les citoyennes et
citoyens en ont notre métier notre
responsabilité professionnelle
c'est là dessus que nous sommes jugés
c'est de produire d'effet des
informations pas des grandes vérité avec
un grand v mais ces éléments factuels
sévérité de fait qui sont recoupées
documenté et qui permettent de nourrir
le débat public on est au coeur d'un
enjeu et d'une alerte je comprends tout
à fait sénateur hugonnet je n'ai pas
employé le terme dictature jeudi depuis
très longtemps démocratie de basse
intensité c'était mendès-france 1 qui
disait la démocratie c'est une culture
c'est pas simplement des institutions
c'est une façon d'être et en
l'occurrence au coeur de sa en prenant
une référence plus proche que bailly
vous avez le manifeste intellectuelle et
philosophique du journaliste pour moi
est un texte d'anna arendt nul hasard
l'auteur des origines du totalitarisme
qui s'appelle en anglais trop fan
politics dans le new yorker vérité
politique c'est dans le recueil crise de
la culture et de rappel cette chose
essentielle et c'est ce qui est en péril
aujourd'hui dans un pays particulier qui
n'est pas l'allemagne qui n'est pas la
grande bretagne qui n'est pas l'italie
qui n'est pas l'espagne qui n'est pas
les états unis même si monsieur trump a
tenté qui est la france qui est la
france elle dit que les vérités les plus
fragiles ce sont ces vérités de fait que
produisent les journalistes sur le
présent sur le passé alors que les
vérités d'opinion elles ne sont pas
menacés nous vivons un moment c'est ce
que nous vivons de manière sidéré tous
actuellement c'est comment les opinions
sont en train de tuer l'information on
peut aujourd'hui dire des énormités sur
notre passé des énormités sur vichy des
énormités sur la culpabilité évidemment
il est est innocent de dreyfus des
énormités sur nos compatriotes de
culture de croyance ou d'origine
musulmane des universités des énormités
sur la diversité de notre peuple des
idéologies du l'inégalité naturelles qui
sont opposés radicalement à l'article
premier de la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et on peut le dire à antennes
déployées nous sommes dans ce moment là
comment défendre l'indépendance la
vitalité de l'information et nous
achetons aujourd'hui à une vague une
vague qui nous emporte qui domine ce
débat public
ce qui m'amène à la question de la
télévision que vous avez tous les deux
pauses et
le csa aujourd'hui art comme pour moi je
suis sidéré j'ai fait ce que vous avez
tous fait j'ai repris les conventions
une fréquence hertzienne c'est un bien
public nous nous sommes les entreprises
privées faisant partie du pluralisme
avec une loi républicaine formidable la
loi de 1881 à l' usage avec une
jurisprudence très et qui d'ailleurs est
très liée à la qualité du métier à la
diffamation ça veut dire l'intérêt
public le sérieux de l'anc est le
respect du contradictoire donc quand le
csa où l'art comme aujourd'hui c'est une
fréquence ils cèdent un bien public dans
des circonstances qui sont aujourd'hui
discutable puisque certains carrément
les revendre après pour faire fortune ce
qui est un problème or quand même j'ai
devant moi celle
du 27 novembre 2019 qui concerne si news
pluralisme de l'expression des courants
de pensée s'engager à ne pas encourager
les comportements discriminatoires en
raison de la race de l'origine du sexe
de l'orientation sexuelle de la religion
de la nationalité à promouvoir les
valeurs d'intégration et de solidarité
qui sont celles de la république pour
moi je ne comprends pas comment cette
chaîne peut continuer à exister alors
qu'elle s'est engagée à cela donc ma
réponse si je voulais c'est que le jeu
serait gelé lu cette déclaration
directeur de l'information de ses new
skies a d'ailleurs est-ce que tu n'aies
leur d'ailleurs pas par vous lui
répondez dit qu'ils la respectent donc
ce que je veux dire c'est que le
pluralisme dans notre part il fait
partie d'un pluralisme lié aussi à la
vitalité des entreprises en leur en
l'occurrence quand il s'agit de chaînes
hertziennes en accès libre et gratuit
c'est un bien commun et là il doit y
avoir des conditions de contrôle qui ne
peuvent pas en faire des chaînes
d'opinion ce n'est pas possible
autrement nous sommes écartés dans notre
pluralisme et notre diversité
ce qui m'amène question du sénateur
l'objet
est ce que au fond la concentration ne
sauve pas des médias mais la question
c'est est ce que l ai fait d'une part au
détriment du débat public de sa qualité
mais surtout et elle fait pour en rester
sur le terrain économique dans le cadre
d'une concurrence non libre et faussée
ce qui est le cas c'est tous les
chiffres que je vous ai que je vous ai
cités tout à l'heure il n'y a pas la
vérité des prix les chiffres de ces
médias ne seraient pas les mêmes s'il
n'y avait pas les aides publiques s'il
n'y avait pas les accords secrets avec
les gammes les résultats qu'il proclame
donc la question s'est sauvé mais sauvé
dans une vérité des prix économiques
n'ont sauvé dans un respect de
l'honnêteté du débat public non donc là
il y a il y a
une vraie question qui rejoint mes
propositions je vais les rappeler que je
puisse que madame robert miny invitait
je pense que les aides directes cette
tradition française comme vous disiez
monsieur hugo nez nous avons défendu le
spill depuis le début et nous ne sommes
pas les seuls même monsieur au lit
monsieur roch mais ce qui est
aujourd'hui le président de l'art comme
a fait un rapport la cour des comptes a
fait les rapports cette exception
française des aides directes
et un archaïsme total
les aides indirectes c'est autre chose
c'est une aide elles sont fiscales elles
sont sociales elles sont postale c'est
une aide à l'écosystème les aides
directes c'est directement aux
entreprises ce n'est pas admissible
c'est nous devons arriver à un système
qui vit sainement et ou du coup il ya la
vérité des prix et où les rédactions du
coup se batte pour elle même parce que
si on sait qu'on a les aides publiques
d'un côté et le mécène oligarques qui
arrive de l'autre du coup on ne se bat
plus on survit grâce à d'autres hélas la
vitalité de notre profession dépend
aussi du fait qu'on arrête c'est bouée
de sauvetage deuxièmement je les dis
mettre fin à l'opacité un journal qui en
plus est au coeur du débat public on
doit connaître son actionnariat il doit
être transparent ainsi que toutes les
subventions et aides qu'il reçoit
troisièmement il faut limiter la
concentration verticale il faut revenir
parce qu'elle devient lé haut à
l'argument du champion français elle est
aujourd'hui vue sans limites et elles
s'ajoutent je le redis à une
concentration verticale qui est même au
coeur de nos métiers la publicité la
communication
donc il y a quelque chose qui doit être
posée autour du conflit d'intérêts il
n'est pas légitime qu'il y ait tant
d'activités non journalistique non
éditorial qui interviennent
contrairement aux paysages qui vous a
été fait tout à l'heure les grandes
en pions de l'information dans des
démocraties vivantes sont faits par des
industriels de l'information non pas des
industriels de l'armement du luxe de la
téléphonie et ainsi de suite ce qui
m'amène à mon énième proposition dans la
mesure où nous sommes dans cette
situation en france vous devez donner
des droits juridiques moreau aux
rédactions qui y compris par rapport à
votre inquiétude sénateurs hugonnet
puisse si vous veillez aussi pour le
service public pour que le service
public soit indépendant des gouvernants
c'est à dire que les rédactions puisse
avoir un droit sur le choix des
responsables éditoriaux et sur la
révocation
c'est un principe est évident c'est le
cas chez nous c'est le cas partout
c'était le cas dans la tradition du
journal le monde dans la tradition du
journal libération quand il était
contrôlé par les personnels et c'est un
gage de confiance
enfin sur les questions très précises
que m'a posé le sénateur logis je
devrais pas les les oublier et on
remerciant le sénateur hugo les sur sa
lecture de média pas je rappelle que
nous sommes quand même ce qu'ils font
sur tous ces sujets là y compris la
mission d'information de l'assemblée
nationale les articles les plus longs
les plus détaillées les plus documentés
petit détail intéressant le rapport de
la mission d'information de l'assemblée
nationale n'a donné lieu le lendemain
qu'à une petite dépêche afp il est sur
une question centrale qui à la question
des plateformes et de l'écosystème je
suis cité et la commission la mission
d'information se revendiquent de ce que
je lui ai dit dans son rapport ce qui
prouve que tout ça n'est pas partisan
c'est une collègue de votre party les
républicains qui préside cette
commission est bien savez vous quoi
alors que ça concerne le système
médiatique mais qui savent mais un
problème sur ces médias qui ont refusé
la transparence sur les accord de gré à
gré qu'ils font avec les plateformes
google et facebook pas d'article dans le
monde pas d'article dans le figaro pas
d'article dans libération est
intéressant alors que c'est un sujet
pour tout rubrique médias évident je
réponds très précisément et très
brièvement nous sommes aujourd'hui 65
journalistes en cdi sur 120 salariés
tout est internalisé à mediapart la
relation avec les abonnés l'informatique
la gestion le marketing et nous avons en
gros 70 collaborateurs pigistes
réguliers donc 65
+70 nous les recrutons sur des critères
professionnels de qualité
professionnelle que vous pouvez juger
sur pièce mais nous veillons d'une part
à la nouvelle génération nous les
fondateurs nous sommes sur le sur le
déclin j'allais dire aujourd'hui
mediapart effet dans tous les secteurs
par une génération qui a entre 35 et 40
et 45 ans c'est eux qui font c'est une
génération qui qui a qui a l'âge de ma
fille c'est une autre génération et
c'est ça qui est pour moi la réussite de
mediapart c'est la transmission à une
autre génération de cette tradition dont
nous dont nous dont nous venons
sur deux le dernier point sur la liberté
d'expression c'était votre question j'ai
oublié de préciser quelque chose qui est
important et qui est important par
rapport aux promesses démocratiques de
la révolution numérique entre le moment
nous nous sommes créé aujourd'hui il y a
eu une grande régression qui
s'accompagne de l'ascension des réseaux
sociaux avec toute la dégradation que
vous avez que vous voyez en part en
particulier eh bien nous sommes les
seuls à avoir maintenu le cap c'est le
sens de mediapart un journal
participatif
totalement participatif à mediapart tout
abonné peut bloguer commenter librement
dans une culture de free speech
c'est-à-dire de liberté d'expression et
de contrôle a posteriori qui fonctionne
bien et qui fait que aujourd'hui
mediapart marche sur deux jambes les
informations que nous produisons et le
libre débat d'opinion de nos abonnés et
femmes ce cap qui nous qui veut dire des
investissements nous avons dix personnes
qui s'occupent chez nous bio la relation
éditorial du club des participatif de
l'expression sur les réseaux sociaux qui
sont en cdi nous n'avons pas c'était un
enjeu et j'en termine c'était important
de montrer que la révolution dit ital
indépendamment de la défense de la
qualité ce que j'ai dit dans ma première
intervention défendent le meilleur de la
tradition dans la modernité numérique
mais c'était aussi important de montrer
que ce n'était pas le lieu de la
création de la précarité c'était la
création d'emplois véritable de
compétences véritable et j'ai oublié un
point mediapart à tout niveau et
totalement paritaire hommes enfin moitié
moitié dernière série de questions
monique de marco derrière son écran
choisir un sujet qui n'a pas été abordée
j'avais d'autres questions mais faute de
temps je pose celle ci que pensez-vous
de la pratique des ménages qui consiste
pour un finaliste assuré une prestation
rémunérée aux amis d'une entreprise ou
d'un lobby ne pensez vous pas qu'il ya
mélange des genres est bien sûr un
risque de conflit de conflit d'intérêts
ne serait-il pas nécessaire de légiférer
sur ce suivi est également
merci vincent capo-canellas
merci monsieur le président moi je
retiens de l' échange d'abord que comme
monsieur plenel les ai tout à l'heure
vous êtes tous des journalistes avec un
projet éditorial
et que ça devient une denrée rare parce
qu'effectivement robert se le dise tout
à l'heure je crois quand on regarde
certaines télés déconne écouter radio
est assez largement sur les radios
d'ailleurs de plus en plus on a des
commentaires par des non journalistes
alors comment lutter contre cette
banalisation qui fait que rond on
véhicule des opinions est pas d
information et qu'on n'a pas
l'arrière-plan le savoir-faire la mise
en perspective du dd des journalistes ça
me paraît un point vous avez beaucoup
fait ressortir qu'ils n'étaient pas
présents jusque là dans nos débats
deuxièmement sur la relation avec la
sphère économique et sur le besoin de
capitaliser quand même alors on a
compris vous vos process vous aviez un
projet éditorial et vous avez su drainer
à l'orgue avec des façons de cantonner
les choses entre guillemets les
investisseurs soit en les lâchant après
ok en rachetant soit on trouve en une
fois mais bon monsieur b tout à l'heure
1 un dispositif que je trouve très
intéressant qui me paraît assez
singulier c'est là qu'il faut arriver à
expliquer à des investisseurs que sur le
projet éditorial il ya une muraille
complète est-ce que ça ça vous paraît
reproductible parce que ça me paraît un
schéma quand je vous vois indépendant je
me dis c'est le très bien mais est ce
qu'à un moment donné vous n'avez pas
être sous capitalisées et je voulais pas
finir par hamon ont donné avec une crise
l'autre chose avoir une difficulté bon
du coup voilà où est ce qu'on met le
curseur est ce que c'est dans la la
muraille de chine et dans la régulation
dans un projet tauriel fort et les
investisseurs savent que ben là s'arrête
là leurs capacités si j'ose dire ou est
ce que c'est vraiment faim là est ce
qu'on peut dire non non pas
d'investisseurs du tout j'ai du mal à y
croire pour la bombe donc comment vous
voyez ça parce que sinon après qu'est ce
qu'on fait on interdit les les grands
groupes
tout à l'heure que certains parler de la
loyère sambre ça a été contournée donc
nous on est un peu sceptique on est
législateur regardons le sujet mais si
on parvenait pas la même analyse tous
arbres si on part du point de vue qu'il
ya trop de concentration qu'est ce qu'on
fait est ce qu on l'interdît est ce
qu'on la réguler comment on peut avancer
sur les conflits d'intérêts potentiels
bon avec cette réalité quand même qu'on
a quand même toujours besoin
d'investisseurs me semble-t-il dans une
économie malgré tout libéral a appuyé de
deuxième point monsieur plenel profite
là à parler de la transparence dans les
liens avec les plateformes qu'est ce que
vous voulez dire par là et qu'est ce que
vous nous suggériez de regarder
je me mets dans la continuité notamment
des questions économiques qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la proposition qui a été
faite d essayer d'encadrer l'affectation
des ressources publicitaires pour éviter
un transfert trop massif s'il n'a pas
déjà eu lieu sur le numérique mais de
faire qu'un
prescripteurs
soit dans l'obligation de diversifier
[Musique]
qui mais c'est leur apportera corps
normalement à la fin je pose la dernière
question autant on est assez avancé dans
leur autant que je la pose maintenant
comme ça elle peut s'intégrer aux
réponses que vous voulez apporter à mes
collègues
la réflexion qu'on va avoir
j'aimerais bien avoir votre éclairage
voix de point de vue
c'est quand on va faire des propositions
soit en gros tout le monde va tomber
d'accord même si c'est pas avec les
mêmes analyses sur le fait qu' il ya des
concentrations un nouveau paysage et que
la loi de 86 et obsolète donc on va
réfléchir comme législateur à notre plat
de ckoi l'obsolescence certains vont
peut-être penser j'ai tendance à le
croire qu' il faut libéraliser
complètement les règles qui existent et
et d'autres qui vont penser c'est à dire
les enlever est-ce qu'elle entrave
et d'autres peuvent penser qu'au
contraire il faut les renforcer
notamment
aussi dans des domaines où elle n'avait
pas pu
bien des choses et ça a été dit les
fournisseurs d'accès
moi mes questions précises sous les
suivants
aujourd'hui les dans la loi 86 les
concentrations horizontales sont
réglementés on peut pas avoir plus de
temps de chaîne
au début c'était assez peu maintenant
c'est quand même déjà pas mal ces sept
est ce qu'on doit re baisser le seuil
sur l'horizontale
ensuite il ya des concentrations
diagonale accepté il ya des conseillers
concentration diagonale et on dit on ne
peut pas c'est à dire à l'époque c'était
on à la radio on à voir une télé
on peut pas être présent sur un
troisième support presse écrite où on
est présent sur la presse écrite la
radio on peut pas être sûr
et en plus la définition de la presse
écrite était une presse quotidienne
d'information générale qui couvre plus
de 20% du territoire comme si c'était le
seul lieu d' influence de la presse
écrite qui semble un petit peu caduque
aussi et surtout que je crois plus
personne ne peut détenir plus de 20%
donc en fait
c'est une règle qui qui qui n'est
aujourd'hui il ya deux autres sujets qui
ont été posées par certains d'entre vous
et notamment sur la publicité par edwy
plenel il ya est ce que on limite où on
interdit complètement
additionné au reste la possession de
régies publicitaires
et l'autre question qui n'est pas la
même et qui est aussi un au dessus notre
concentration la question des
fournisseurs d'accès est ce qu'on peut
avoir les tuyaux et être dans les
contenus et dans la diffusion des
contenus donc si on devait changer les
règles pour limiter qu'est ce que l'on
pourrait faire je dis ça pourquoi parce
que c'est là où le législateur peut
bouger des règles
mais à chaque fois que j'ai voulu
légiférer sur les concentrations et
depuis 2008 monsieur art est une chose
c'est que la loi n'est pas rétroactive
et que sa tendance donc quand on pense
à la façon de réguler cela on est devant
un sujet c'est que ceux qui sont en
place reste en place
et on empêche les nouveaux entrants de
pouvoir avoir des armes égales y compris
pour y aller donc c'est un vrai sujet de
comment on peut faire ça c'est pour cela
et c'est ma question que je repose parce
qu'on n'y a pas répondu complètement
c'est pour ça que souvent c'est mieux on
s'est dit bon il y as on peut réguler le
nombre de chaînes et que sarenza mais il
ya quelque chose qui peut s'imposer à
tous
et la loi est active et opérante tout de
suite c'est protéger les rédactions
quelles que soient les mouvements
capitalistiques qui a autour c'est
protéger les rédactions de ces
mouvements là parce que qu'on soit en
entrant ou déjà installé avec des
monopoles et je je je je c'est pour ça
que je redemande parce que bien entendu
que j'ai travaillé comme tous les
législateurs sur la loi dite bloch et
elle est insuffisante
parce que ce statut juridique et c'est
les obligations qu'on avait de faire des
comités éthiques et serra se sont
avérées à géométrie variable et donc
c'est quoi un statut juridique qui
protège et qui y compris dans la presse
écrite
où il ya de la presse d'opinion protège
ceux qui ont créé ces organes et qui
je pense à l'humanité a d'autres qui ont
des orientations donc comment protège
des rédactions des propriétaires
dans des domaines très différents la
presse écrite ou la télé et la télé ça a
été rappelé qu'on parle pas de la télé
numérique ou pas des deux des droits des
maîtres qui sont des concessions d'état
faite par l'art comme dans le cas des
conventions et où jusqu'à présent
jamais jamais n'a été conçu l'idée de
chêne d'opinion parce que même les je
parle de toutes les chaînes pas
seulement d'information mais les chaînes
d'information étaient conçus comme des
chaînes d'information et pas des chaînes
de débats or quand vous regardez le
temps d'antenne il y a à 90%
probablement j'ai pas mesurer exactement
du débat mais la recherche de
l'information avec des reportages avec
de l'enquète etc n'existe et la portion
congrue donc ça ça peut être aussi
rectifié dans les règles dans les
propositions qu'on fera dans notre
rapport mais je veux avoir votre avis
sur c'est quoi un statut juridique des
rédactions propre qui protège il ya des
modèles il ya le monde il ya chez vous
il ya à libé est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
modèles des règles pour être pour tous
mpt voilà c'était les dernières
questions on vous laisse vous saisir de
telle ou telle question si vous pouviez
au moins faire en sorte qu'ils aient une
réponse à chacune je ne sais pas qui se
lance
allez-y monsieur plenel
toutes les questions sont au coeur du
sujet
je comprends tout à fait la difficulté
de votre tâche vu le temps passer vous
connaissez mon plaidoyer régulier pour
un parlementarisme français qui est soit
pas affaibli par le présidentialisme
combien soum sous les trois présidentes
récente l'actuel la précédente et
l'avant précédente hélas tous ceux que
vous affrontez a été accompagné par ses
présidences et d y compris avec des
interventions parfois
directe de la présidence de la
république dans ce mouvement de
concentration quelles que soient les
étiquettes politiques des présidents
donc je comprends tout à fait votre
difficulté y compris par rapport à ceux
passés à cet héritage
le premier objectif je répète ma formule
sur l'écosystème des médias c'est que
vous fassiez en sorte que nous ne soyons
plus à armes inégales nous sommes à
armes inégales le meilleur exemple
monsieur le président la faune est
justement ce qui se joue autour des
plateformes et des droits voisins vos
collègues de l'assemblée nationale ont
parfaitement établi la question des
droits voisins notre syndicat fait
partie de l'organisme de gestion
collectif présidé par jean marie cavada
notre co fondatrice marie hélène y
siégeant et au conseil surveillance de
set au jeu au gc qui défend cette idée
simple que la manne des droits voisins
du droit d'auteur que doivent ces
plateformes qui s'enrichissent au
détriment au détriment des médias une
évaluation que fait jean marie cavada
votre collègue qui a été longtemps au
parlement européen et qui est un ancien
journaliste entre 800 millions et un
milliard d'euros
nous défendons une position saine normal
il y as avec nous le syndicat des
éditeurs de magazines lit avec nous la
sacem qui a son expérience sur les
droits d'auteur de la musique que cette
manne doit être gérée collectivement de
façon transparente et pas dans des
accords de gré à gré le monde
le figaro libération
et ainsi de suite fondé accord de gré à
gré et temps les plateformes que les
responsables de ces médias les
directeurs directeurs qui ne sont pas
des journalistes je le rappelle le se
sont opposés à la représentation
parlementaire ils sont opposé le secret
des affaires sur le contenu de ces
accords donc il y a là un enjeu terrible
terrible si nous n'y arrivons pas c'est
l'écosystème médiatique qui sera
transformé radicalement avec des abus
radicaux de position dominante
le directeur du monde louis dreyfus l'a
défendu devant les parlementaires il a
dit nous sommes les plus forts et bien
c'est normal et donc nous y allons et
donc primo premier de cordée j'allais
dire puisque cette formule est à la mode
au détriment du pluralisme au détriment
de la diversité
ce n'est pas possible ce sont ce qu'on
appelle en droit de la concurrence et
vous savez que la commission de la
concurrence et à nouveau saisi des abus
de position dominante
il ya un premier enjeu déjà faire une
digue faire une digue deuxièmement sur
la concentration et même il y à des
incompatibilités que vous devez énoncés
oui il est incompatible que des grands
opérateurs de la publicité soit
directement
opérateurs de médias je le dis d'autant
plus que nous n'avons pas de publicité
notre seul slogan ses seuls nos lecteurs
peuvent nous acheter nous abonnés mais
si la publicité et larmes des
propriétaires de médias premièrement
leurs médias peuvent en profiter plus
massivement que d'autres et deuxièmement
comme vous l'avez rappelé d'ailleurs
lors des auditions précédentes elle peut
être une arme pour déstabiliser
l'adversaire quand des contenus de
l'adversaire ne plaisent pas et quand en
plus dans le cas du groupe bolloré cette
publicité s'accompagne d'une agence de
communication que vous connaissez
parfaitement l' agence havas et que nous
retrouvons chargé de d'organiser la
communication des personnes que nous
mettons en difficulté par nos
révolutions et nos informations cela a
une incidence directe sur les médias où
on fait des contre-attaqués jeu
l'exemple le plus caricatural étant les
quatre mois de la sphère cahuzac où nous
avons dû affronter tout un univers
médiatique instrumentalisé par ce monde
de la communication et donc
il ya là premier point la publicité
deuxième point les incompatibilités dans
l'ancienne tradition législatives
c'était avec la commande publique là
vous avez un exemple flagrant comment
des médias qui ont des actionnaires dont
la commande publique et la première
recette je parle du groupe dassault
parce que c'est une commande publique
avec y compris nos gouvernants qui se
font les représentants de commerce de
leurs avions comment comment peuvent-ils
est opérateur direct une grande
démocratie quelles que soient ses
défauts aucune démocratie n'est parfaite
l'inde vie un immense scandale à partir
de révélations de mediapart qui est au
coeur du débat public du parlement
indien c'est la sphère des rafales qui
concerne la france vous envoyer une
ligne dans le figaro jamais même pas une
dépêche responsable sur un journal de
qualité qui est le plus vieux d'entre
nous
qui est celui qui a publié le premier
article de zola dans son engagement qui
allait le faire basculer dans l' affaire
dreyfus pour les juifs c'était en 1896
donc quand même il ya un problème il ya
un problème qui est la très concrets
devant vous donc deuxième exemple
armements et troisième exemple vous
l'avez dit les tuyaux eh bien oui il
faut empêcher vous avez un super exemple
y compris documenté par l'administration
fiscale
quand mediapart en entraînant tout le
monde et je ne reviendrai pas sur la
mauvaise manière qui nous a été fait
après a emmené la bataille gagnée en
france en 2014 gagné en europe en 2018
sur l'égalité du taux de tva qui est une
aide indirecte et non pas aux
entreprises de presse mais au lecteur
pour que la presse soit accessible de
tous pour que le taux de tva soit le
même de 1% et non pas 20 % la tva
super-réduit qui est une aide
traditionnel à ce bien démocratique
qu'est l'information qu'a fait sfr
presse
il a fait une offre groupée de ses
bouquets y compris audio visuels et
autres en y mettant ses journaux à
l'époque l'express libération magnin 6,8
à quel taux à
2,1
et en étendant le taux de la presse à
tout le monde ils on n'en parle pas mais
ils ont été lourdement redresser
fiscalement pour cette entourloupe à la
tva
plusieurs c'est là qu'ils ont appliqué
le taux super réduit à des activités qui
ne pouvaient pas l'être c'est à dire les
activités de leur groupe de
2,2 portail d'accès de téléphonie et
ainsi de suite donc là vous avez trois
exemples d'incompatibilité sur lesquels
vous devez vous devez intervenir pour
terminer et l'enjeu en effet c'est
protéger les rédactions dans tous les
cas de figure puis je vous rappeler ce
que dit la charte européenne que toutes
les organisations de journalistes site
depuis
1971 la responsabilité des journalistes
vis-à-vis du public prime toute autre
responsabilité en particulier à l'égard
de leur employeur et des pouvoirs
publics
jeu charte dite de munich parce qu'elle
a été proclamée à munich et donc il nous
faut cette protection
c'est cette protection qui a été
piétinée et bafoué dans la dernière
personne de ce point de vue pour
terminer sur l'écosystème je me suis
aperçu que j'avais pas répondu à une de
vos questions pour éclairer votre
votre commission ce que nous avons créé
n'est pas du tout un fonds
d'investissement c'est à partir des
fonds de dotation qui existe depuis 2008
dans le secteur de la culture nous avons
inventé un fonds de dotation ça veut
dire souplesse juridique des
associations souplesse financière des
fondations qui s'appelle le fpr qui a
donc eu et légitimé par son intérêt
public à recevoir des dons défiscalisés
de particuliers ou d'entités ils
n'aident pas médiapart il sent que tu as
he is en étant l'actionnaire unique de
mediapart via la société pour la
protection d'indépendance de mediapart
qui sanctuarisent le capital de
médiapart mediapart ne peut pas recevoir
d'argent de lui
mediapart en revanche est contraint de
verser une partie de ses profits afp l
aube énéfice de l'écosystème et le f pl
il en est à son quatrième appel à
projets le fpm avec l'argent qu'ils
collectent dont celui de médiapart mais
de particuliers vous pouvez y contribuer
si vous voulez aide des médias
indépendants à vivre a fait revivre leur
projet avec une commission d'étude tout
à fait professionnel dans vos régions
vous pouvez en connaître aussi bien dans
le sud-ouest dans le sud-est et à et
ailleurs et dans la diversité compris je
pense actuellement ils sont en reportage
en afghanistan un journal qui a été
créée en ligne par un réfugié afghan qui
est aujourd'hui un reportage pour nous
en afghanistan même ils ont créé et
geeti news qui est un journal autour des
migrants et bien que le fpr a aidé que
le fpr a aidé de manière très
professionnelle donc ce fonds pour une
presse libre essaye par rapport à ce que
disait mon collègue eric fottorino
essaye de pallier l'absence de
volontarisme d'autres
d'autres d'autres
d'autres instances pour aider à ce pur
alisme et d'un journalisme de qualité
d'un journalisme indépendant donc voila
nous nous attendons ça et je voudrais
partir sur une note d'humour quand je
parle d'écosystèmes pour que vous compte
renier bien vous avez tous entendu
parler et vos enfants vous en ont parlé
de dons de cup sur netflix par rapport
aux changements climatiques
ce film qui les indépendants sauver
hollywood quelque part netflix et le
gros business et il produit ce film qui
est une fable sur la catastrophe
climatique mais si vous allez le voir
c'est un film d'une impitoyable sur la
présidence américaine
impitoyable sur le monde des médias
impitoyable sur la vie politique
impitoyable sur les réseaux sociaux et
sur les télévisions eh bien il est clair
que dans notre système actuel un tel
film avec sa virulence ne pourrait pas
être produits en france ne pourrait pas
être produit c'est ça le libéralisme
n'ont produit aucun avec des vrais
moyens comme cela des vedettes aussi de
l'importance de leonardo dicaprio avec
tout demander à tous les professionnels
qui essaye de faire aboutir des projets
et bien non 1 vous ils ne passeraient
pas parce que le système est aujourd'hui
un système qui est trop imbriquées
je redis encore une fois le libéralisme
c'est la possibilité de deux d'opinions
plutôt d'information qui dérange les
opinions y compris fusse-t-elle de la
majorité et c'est ça notre travail c'est
ça notre notre rôle d'aiguillon
démocratique dans la diversité de nos
sensibilités merci qui prend la suite
[Musique]
alors je vais pas être aussi exhaustifs
que khedri mais je voudrais quand même
essayer de répondre à vos questions
sénateur assouline on repasse en parce
que nous a demandé le sénateur
capo-canellas en particulier sur cette
uniformisation ce don ce qui nous menace
aujourd'hui c'est une initialisation
consensuelle de l'information vous
finalement
lorsque des propriétaires puissants sont
à la tête de grands groupes de presse
les possèdent on sera perçoit et qui
s'en aperçoit les lecteurs les lecteurs
les auditeurs et les téléspectateurs
quand on est sur une radio mais je parle
de la presse écrite ou de la presse
numérique aussi haut on lit eh bien on
voit quelque chose qui se ressemblent
tous ressemble à tous et sur tourner
dérange pas trop et cette uniformisation
elle est un grand danger parce
qu'effectivement
elle est ce qui fait ou ne fait pas
notre lien avec les lecteurs avec les
citoyens qui vont voter et qui vivent au
jour le jour dans un pays dont ils se
sentent éloignés et des dirigeants et de
tous ceux qui ont du pouvoir
quelles qu'elles soient toutes les
autorités et notre rôle nous de médias
est très important d'autant plus
important que dans la complexité
ambiante on veut toujours avoir de la
simplicité on préfère un mensonge simple
qu'une réalité complexe une vérité
complexe et nous on est d'une certaine
manière des artisans de cette complexité
autrement c'est très facile d'aller dans
le sens de des algorithmes de d'aller
dans le sens de l'opinion qui qui veut
plus être rassuré que être éclairer
quelques fois
alors si vous voulez
bien sûr j'espère que les lois peuvent
faire quelque chose on est dans une
démocratie qui est un peu trop
présidentielle est un peu trop peu
parlementaire mais vous l'avez dit
sur le rapporteur le
les lois se sont pas rétroactives donc
ce qui est fait est fait et ce qui a été
défait a été fortement des faits
qu'est-ce qui a été défait et bien
précisément la capacité que peuvent
avoir des rédactions
de cette ambition d'informer librement
avec obstination l'obstination c'était
un des quatre commandements de camus
avec la lucidité et l'ironie et c'est
l'obstination et aujourd'hui on a le
sentiment que nos médias du fait qu'ils
sont la propriété de ces de ces
puissants cherche toujours un peu où il
ya déjà de la lumière est assez peu là
où il ya de l'ombre est en fait notre
métier c'est d'éclairer la houille à
l'ombre là où il la lumière c'est
aveuglant et d'une certaine manière
l'actualité c'est ce qui ça et bluey la
profondeur des choses c'est c'était en
arène qui disait aussi ça c'est que
l'actualité était trop éblouissante et
donc ne nous à nous empêcher d'aller
chercher cette vérité
j'aimerais bien vous donner des outils
vous dire oui faisons des fondations
faisons des des fonds de soutien etc
associons les lecteurs pour qu'ils
financent des reportages tout ça existe
d'ailleurs
mais plein d'outils mis l'outil ne font
pas une volonté et une puissance et
quand on dit que les médias son
quatrième pouvoir aujourd'hui je pense
qu'au contraire ils ont été très
dévalorisée diminué dans leur influence
parce que précisément la confiance est
perdue donc on va pas de demain demander
à monsieur bolloré à monsieur arnaud de
de tout lâcher de tout de tout rendre
c'est pas ça ce serait absurde
en revanche je pense effectivement moi
aussi je suis dans la transmission on a
25 jeunes chez nous et ils ont entre 25
et 35 ans et quand je vois l'ambition
qu'ils ont eux de faire leur métier moi
j'ai envie de leur donner les moyens de
sa vous voyez aujourd'hui on parle des
personnalités juridiques qu'on veut
donner à des fleuves voix des montagnes
je pense qu'il faut absolument donner
des personnalités juridiques à des
rédactions mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire donner ester en justice pour une
rédaction ça veut dire autrefois on
parlait enfin autre fois il ya quinze
ans il ya vingt ans on parlait d'une
muraille de chine la muraille de chine
intangible infranchissable entre les
intérêts du capital d'un côté entre les
intérêts de la rédaction de l'autre et
qui ne pouvait y avoir aucun passe-droit
aucune possibilité de l'actionnaire du
propriétaire de décrocher son téléphone
et de dire au directeur de la rédaction
ah ben ça serait quand même bien que
vous parliez de sa serai je serais
ennuyé si vous parliez de ça moi je l'
ai vécu pendant six mois lorsque j'étais
encore directeur du monde avec les
nouveaux actionnaires du monde je sais
très bien ce que ça voulait dire quand
on nous disait il faudrait quand même ne
soutenir strauss kahn bon il ya eu des
événements qui ont fait qu'il n'a pas
été soutenue mais si vous voulez cette
muraille de chine elle est poreuse
partout et donc si vous voulez je ne
suis pas sûr que ce soit une loi keane
qui nous permette demain d'avoir une
protection des rédactions pour vraiment
faire leur boulot est ce que vous
imaginez une seconde moi j'ai vécu
quelque chose qui m'a fait de la peine
pour lui et paix à son âme c'est etienne
mougeotte je me souviens d'un jour dans
le don le figaro que nicolas a dirigé
il ya eu deux pages d'entretien du
patron de dassault aviation signé par
etienne mougeotte et je me suis dit mais
qu'est ce qui a fait qu'à un moment
donné le patron du journal va
interviewer un des représentants de
l'actionnaire ce journalisme là alors
que le figaro est un très bon journal il
ya de très bons papiers dans le figaro
un très bon journaliste je veux dire par
là que quand vous êtes déjà sous le
contrôle d'un actionnaire il ya deux
moments où on va vous le rappeler
fortement le premier moment c'est quand
ses intérêts son domaine privé est en
jeu donc son activité concurrentielle et
le deuxième moment c'est évidemment les
élections présidentielles puisque la ya
des contrats publics ya des marchés
publics il ya des liens à avoir avec les
uns et les autres mais si certains
jouent au mal un essai de deux misé sur
tout le monde donc si vous voulez moi la
question
vous savez cette et kundera qui disait
un roman n'a pas réponse à tout la
question à tous moi je pense que nous
notre travail c'est d'avoir question à
tous on n'a pas réponse à tout moi je ne
sais pas vous dire quel outil il faut
que vous créiez mais ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que si dans les années qui
viennent on n'a pas une un corpus à la
fois en effet réglementaire législatif
mais au-delà de ça une volonté politique
une lucidité politique des dirigeants
pour comprendre qu'une démocratie faible
se mesure à la faiblesse de ses
institutions médiatiques et bien
effectivement demain ce sera le
populiste qui le qui l'emportera parce
que précisément les lecteurs les
citoyens seront allés chercher ce qu'ils
croient être des informations sur des
supports délirant qui auront été
simplement le le ricochet où l'effet
boomerang de nos supports devenus eux
aussi délirants pour d'autres raisons
[Musique]
tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit et et c'est vrai que des
journalistes sont pas le bras armé de la
justice on est le bras qui est que seul
le bras armé de la justice et
moi je peux pas vous écrire votre loi
c'est votre métier à tous mais je peux
je peux souligner ce qui ne va pas et
dans les choses qui n'auront pas vous
vous lavez soulevé monsieur assouline il
ya la règle des 2 sur 3 par exemple qui
me prend en compte que la presse
quotidienne
il faudrait que toutes sortes de presse
put puissent être prises prises en
compte
il ya le problème du fait que
aujourd'hui les concentrations s'évalue
sur des bassins de population et de
diffusion or aucun titre de presse même
même de pqr
ne les attends donc là ça ne va pas
effectivement vous avez dit que vous
avez participé à la bo ration de la
guadeloupe aujourd'hui elle se révèle
inopérante voire contre-productive quand
et là encore je soulève un problème ce
que vous savez que pour faire écrire la
charte d'éthique de ses news la
direction a
reformé en toute hâte une une société
des journalistes à sa main qui a rédigé
une charte et on va aborder un autre
sujet notre question qui a été posée qui
a rédigé une charte qui en fait autorise
les ménages qui a été l'objet d'une des
questions autorise les ménages ah oui je
les voulais vous la trouverez sur les
jours mais je jouis je peux vous la
faire envoyez donc elle cette charte
autorise les ménages et moi
effectivement je pense que les ménages
devraient être tout bonnement interdite
voilà c'est ses
facettes ça n'a rien à voir avec le
journalisme ces essais et c'est là où en
fait
alors un ménage c'est quand on va
employer un journaliste au service d'une
industrie pour qu'il fasse semblant de
faire son rôle de journaliste et
promeuvent cette industrie voilà c'est
ça un ménage donc ça devrait être tout
simplement tout simplement interdit et
en ce qui concerne le comité d'éthique
toujours par rapport à la loi bloch même
chose c'est toujours l'exemple qui en
devient presque caricatural de toute
façon bolloré mais c'est ainsi par
exemple le comité d'éthique de canal+ au
moment où eric zemmour a fait la sortie
pour laquelle il est condamné
aujourd'hui sont les sur les mineurs
isolés
comité d'éthique a dit aujourd'hui cette
émission face à l'info salou officiers
et reese émond ne peut pas continuer
dans sa forme actuelle
c'était il ya deux ans à ce jour il n'y
a eu aucune réponse aucune modification
à l'émission donc
donc c'est bien la preuve que cette loi
qui qui était louable à l'époque et qui
déjà avait été édulcoré par rapport à ce
qu'est ce qui devait être des parents
est insuffisante donc il faut un vieux
il faut écrire une nouvelle loi voilà je
pense qu'il ya des gens qui vous l'ont
déjà dit un il faut il faut écrire une
nouvelle loi il faut repartir de zéro on
prend la feuille blanche et et on
réécrit au lieu de de ravauder dans les
coins comme on le fait depuis depuis 40
ans
comment protéger des rédactions
effectivement un statut juridique des
rédactions c'est important il ya
plusieurs personnes qui vous ont qui
vous ont raconté comment par exemple les
journalistes d'i télé était allé voir le
csa en disant regardez ce qui nous
arrive on leur avait répondu mais on
peut rien faire aujourd'hui par exemple
le csa qu on accuse souvent de censure
ne peut pas lutter contre la censure il
n'y a pas de délit de censure ça
n'existe pas donc ça a
un statut juridique des rédactions qu'il
faudrait définir précisé
et être très précis pour que cela ne
puisse pas ce puisse pas être contourné
ensuite est nécessaire effectivement
ensuite je crois que ça vous a été
proposé notamment par reporters sans
frontières un délit de trafic
d'influencé en matière de presse
c'est une piste aussi
les son fils parce qu'il est quand même
très tard donc relançant pas la machine
non enfin
s'il vous plaît de maintenant deux
minutes parce que il le temps écouter
voilà j'ai à peu près fini mais un délit
de trafic d'influencé quand un
propriétaire va obliger le propriétaire
d'un média en propriété industrielle va
obliger la rédaction affaire qui un
article qui un reportage qui favorise
son ses activités enfin ça on l'a vu on
l'a vu à l'oeuvre je pars me relancer
dans dix mille exemples mais j'en ai
plein sur notre ami vincent bolloré
notamment sur le togo voilà
[Musique]
oui merci beaucoup
sur les ménages la position de l'opinion
et aménage ccc au delà de ce qu'a dit
madame envers un concert c'est la
plupart du temps un journaliste qui
anime une conférence un colloque une
convention pour soit une entreprise soit
une fédération professionnelle soit
c'est quelque chose qui est assez
courant dans notre métier nous la règle
qu'on a fixés à l'opinion sait que ces
ménages ces prestations doivent être
spécifiquement autorisé et ne sont
jamais rémunéré pour le journaliste
elles sont ce sont des prestations qui
rentre dans le chiffre d'affaires global
chiffre d'affaires global du journal et
en général c'est rémunérés en prise
d'abonnement que nous que nous facturons
donc à ceux qui demandent le ménage donc
c'est une façon me semble-t-il assez
vertueuse de déconnecter le journaliste
lui-même de la puissance économique qui
est pour lequel ils travaillent
le deux je crois que l'idée d'encadrer
l'affectation des ressources
publicitaires c'est une des unes des
suppositions émises ici en fonction de
l'endroit où ces ressources
publicitaires ou cette dépense lui sert
sont effectués par tel ou tel annonceur
jeu je doute que ce soit très efficace
pardon mais
par exemple là
comment est ce que vous comptez une
publicité qui est insérée dans un
journal papier qui a évidemment une
appli et donc qui est lui sur pdf c'est
à dire sur le numérique
la question là et vous rentreriez dans
des dents des complexités qui me
paraissent
c'est largement au delà du faisable
je sais pas si je peux répondre à toutes
les questions je voudrais quand même
vous alerter sur eux
deux points très particulier d'abord une
alerte générale la presse est en mauvais
état la presse est en mauvais état
économique et donc tout ce que nous
disons la part du principe que la presse
pourrait vivre autrement qu'avec de
l'argent par parfois par dizaines de
millions tous les ans qui viennent de
poches profondes pourquoi est ce qu'une
partie de notre débat a été au fond
forcément les nommer comme ça les
milliardaires qui est un sujet différent
de la concentration des médias ce sont
deux sujets différents
qui parfois se s'additionnent mais ce
sont deux sujets différents
pourquoi est ce que ce sont des gens qui
ont énormément d'argent un argent
considérable qui viennent à la rescousse
des médias et parce que ces médias
demande des ressources considérables
pour des taux de retour sur
l'investissement qui sont la plupart du
temps misérable lorsqu'il y à un retour
sur l'investissement
et donc on peut toujours considérer que
tout ça cette 7 e c 2 juste un intérêt
commercial un moment il y à aussi et je
pense que vous devez reconnaître à tous
ces gens qui mettent des dizaines de
millions d'euros dans ses médias il y a
un intérêt général à ce que ces gens là
investissent d'une façon ou d'une autre
après vous pouvez régler
leur influence leur mainmise sur telle
ou telle rédaction mais si vous partez
dans l'idée que ceux qui ont beaucoup
d'argent sont les adversaires d'une
presse libre je vous assure qu'il y aura
plus beaucoup de journaux dans dix ans
parce que encore une fois la presse est
en très mauvais état parce que les coûts
de structure de la presse par des lâches
des successives et du législateur et des
patrons de presse ces coups là sont
quasiment insupportable pourquoi est ce
que les aides existent en france
mais parce que le droit du travail est
telle que les coûts sociaux sont
gigantesques
parce que les imprimeries fonctionne
avec des coûts de fabrication qui sont
deux trois fois supérieur à ce qui se
passe ailleurs ça c'est le résultat
encore une fois de lâcheté successives
ou d'un corpus destatis général qui fait
que la presse en france est quasiment
structurellement déficitaire je parle tu
regardes la presse print la presse
écrite celle des grands titres
historiques que mes confrères en
plusieurs fois évoquée donc je vous
alerte sur le fait qu' il y à un grand
danger et que vous risquez de faire
basculer tout ça dans un monde
d'inconnus absolue dernier point sur la
protection des rédactions
beaucoup de formules existent mais là
aussi je voudrais vous alerter sur un
point que vous devez sûrement comprendre
très facilement aucune entreprise ne
peut durablement vivre avec des salariés
qui sont en opposition frontale avec un
patron
ça ne peut pas exister que ce soit un
média ou un fabricant de petits pois ça
n'existe pas vous ne pouvez pas avoir
une harmonie
dans au fond la défense d'un projet même
économique
si tous ceux qui travaillent à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise sont
structurellement fondamentalement
basiquement opposé à ce que veut faire
le propriétaire est donc comment
est donc et donc
tous les outils peuvent être teints
peuvent être inventés mais si à la fin
de l'histoire vous construisez où vous
vous donnez une façon d'aller vers la
construction de modèles qui seront des
modèles d'opposition absolue alors vous
vous rentrez là aussi dans une période
de l'histoire que vous ne pouvez pas
connaître qui est que ceux qui viennent
sauver les journaux aujourd'hui
deviendront peut être plus demain
lorsque je voulais vous dire merci nous
un arrêt aux autres c'était un peu long
mais je pense que nous avions besoin de
vous poser ces questions et bien sûr de
vous écouter je précise pour mes
collègues que la prochaine édition aura
lieu lundi prochain à 15h30 avec une
table ronde rassemblant les présidents
de france télévisions de radio france
radio france pardon et d'arrêter et que
se déroulera en salle 260